What's up everybody?
Hey,
welcome to the podcast.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by nature
box.
Now,
this is the first time we're ever opening up this nature box in the office is a
tremendous apple freaks.
My kid loves him,
which was your favorite here.
What naturebox is,
if you don't know,
uh,
it's a healthy snacks they shipped to you.
There's a third option,
snack smarter in 2014 with nature box.
Um,
the idea is when 3:00 PM hunger pangs hit,
you can tough it out and get cranky and lightheaded or you can hit the vending
machine and pack on the pounds.
The idea is that they're bringing you the option of healthy snacks delivered to
French toast,
Granola,
salted Carmel,
Pretzel pops,
dark cocoa almonds and more nutritionalist approved.
Nutritionalist approved your fat.
Fucking you want to lose weight.
Yeah.
Zero Trans fats,
zero folk doors,
no high fructose corn syrup and nothing artificial.
Very delicious nature ships for free.
Just like nature does that it doesn't make any sense right now.
Try your first door to the naturebox@fiftypercentoffbygoingtonaturebox.com slash
Rogan that's naturebox.com/rogan get a handle on your health and your hunger.
naturebox.com which ones do you like the best?
I tell you what,
the best ones.
I love the,
uh,
the Lonestar snacks as good to apple fig.
Uh,
the Apple Pie.
Fig Bob,
my daughter loves them.
The best things they have.
Have those rights.
The sesame sticks,
a rice sticks to black and white.
Granolas delicious.
The uh,
the uh,
they have something else that's out of this world.
I mean they have some great stuff.
It's healthy.
It has a sealer patch.
You could close them right back up and eat in the morning.
You know,
they have just great stuff,
man.
I'm eating harvest rice.
They're not bad.
They're not bad at all.
It's actually delicious.
No,
I know.
But the cocoa almonds,
we'll put you over the fucking top.
That cocoa almonds does it late night with law and order type thing.
It's really cool cause they have like the options,
like if you're Vegan or if you might lactose free sway free.
You choose what you want and it shows you what their options and then mail them
to your monthly so it's a good fucking deal guys.
Yeah,
go to nature box where you can order great tasting healthy snacks right to your
door,
naturebox.com/rogan that's naturebox.com/rogan go there and get 50% off your
first order.
That's naturebox.com/rogan and joy yet we're also brought to you by audible.com
audible.com is the Internet number one provider of audio entertainment.
They have over a hundred thousand copies.
They have everything you could ever want to download and listen to whether it's
educational fiction,
nonfiction,
comedy podcast,
stand up.
They have just audio entertainment,
entertainment that you would use if you were on a plane or if you were in
traffic and it,
I've said it time and time again,
but so many people don't utilize this as a way to just be entertained.
Like you won't mind being in your car stuck in traffic.
If you're listening to a really good audio book,
I've sat in my car for like an extra minute because I wanted to like a chapter
to be over.
It's pretty fucking bad ass.
It really does transform the experience of commuting and it's a way to stimulate
your mind while you're in the middle of doing something else.
Jim Norton,
happy endings taste the tales of a meaty breasted.
Zilch.
He reads it himself,
so it's gotta be awesome.
I fucking love Jim Norton,
audible.com go to audible.com forward slash Joe and get one free audio book and
30 free days of audible service.
It's an outstanding resource for audio entertainment and they are a sponsor of
the podcast.
We're also sponsored by Ting.
That's the last one you have to do to a ting is uh,
first of all,
just see the thing about tink slashing their prices.
Yeah.
Who does that?
Who,
who may,
who gives you guys who ever takes money off of the bill?
That's ridiculous.
They cut their data plan.
Yeah.
Ridiculously.
They cut it in half.
They cut their data plan.
They're fucking nuts,
man.
I don't know what they're doing.
They slashed their data prices on the two year anniversary and they did it
permanently,
which I don't know how you do.
How do,
how can you say you do a permanently cause like imagine if you're,
like you said you were selling TVs and you were like,
uh,
Brian's TV service is going to sell TVs for $100 permanently.
We're going to slash prices.
You can't say permanently cause a thousand years from now TV's going to be
expensive as fuck.
And you'd be like,
what about that permanent shit son?
You don't have to start your own new business because you fucked yourself with
your whole,
all that permanent nonsense.
Uh,
that said whatever they're doing it,
I don't know how they're doing it.
It says on the two year anniversary of its launch,
shockingly likable,
mobile phone service,
Ting,
a division of two cows incorporated surprise its customers with a big drop in
data pricing and then a beautiful definition or description,
shockingly likable,
mobile phone service.
That's a really good way to describe it.
Um,
we've been,
uh,
sponsored by Ting for a long time now and everybody that goes to tank saves
money.
All the people that I've sent over there with Chris Ryan or any of the other
friends that we've sent over to ting ting is a mean.
They've saved them.
I think they said that as many as 98%.
That's what it says on their website.
Right?
It's crazy.
Like they're,
they,
they even knocked the per megabyte.
When you go over your plan,
uh,
buy for $2 and 25 cents to $1 and 50 cents.
Um,
having no contract I think is a good thing too.
There's a,
there's a way that you can,
um,
there's a way that you can do it.
Like I think on the other providers,
you have to buy a phone.
It is possible on Psalm to have no contracts and they're starting to open that
up.
Now.
Uh,
I think that's a,
that's something that people are sort of a demanding.
And as the mobile phone companies become more and more competitive,
I think that,
uh,
they're going,
probably embrace that as an option in the future.
[inaudible] has been doing that all along.
Ting has it set up so that they sell the top end android devices.
And what they do is they buy time on the sprint network and uh,
you can use a sprint network just like someone who uses sprint does.
So if any place where you get service with sprint,
you would get service with Ting and just stupid cheap data prices and dope
phones.
I don't like saying dope cause I'm almost 50,
but dope.
Um,
they just have the coolest android phones,
which I've switched over to.
I use an android phone now.
So,
uh,
rogan.ting.com go there and save 25 bucks at any of their new devices.
Check it out,
enjoy it and uh,
and check into all the different phones they have.
The HTC one is another pretty dope android phone.
If you're a person that's been like an iPhone person your whole life and you're
like,
man,
I just fucking,
I don't know if I could make this jump.
You can make the jump.
Trust me.
I did it.
It's easy.
Then the android phones are pretty commensurate now.
They're pretty bad ass.
Notice how you use the word commensurate as if I use it all the time anyway.
rogan.ting.com why Fako round mad flavor
here
tomorrow.
Um,
uh,
on at.com it's got a press release.
We're going to release a results of a Alpha brain.
So,
uh,
ready for that bitches.
Boom.
Dropping it on your head.
I shouldn't say bitches.
When you deal with the company,
it's unprofessional.
Joe Diaz.
Enough with the commercials on it.
Dot Com.
Use a codeword Rogan and save 10% off any and all supplements.
Joe,
we mothers
hit it.
Just totally fucked up.
What happened?
I don't know what happened here.
This is
government,
the Joe Rogan experience.
Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast all day.
Hey,
here we are back in the house again.
Showed Dheas the new blue cigarettes spokesperson.
Stephen Dorff is out and you're in and Jenny Mccarthy could suck my dick.
No,
no,
no.
Just keep her,
keep her,
keep her eyes.
She's so pretty.
I just like to look at her.
She is getting prettier.
She really is beautiful that that check.
And as she's gotten older,
I mean,
you know,
everybody gets mad at her and they're down on her for what they called the
pseudo science about a vaccination.
She's like a real strong opponent of vaccinations and you know,
a lot of people felt like she had no business doing that.
She didn't understand the science behind it.
She didn't understand like,
you know,
how many people are saved by vaccinations and how dangerous it is.
So to this day I see people taking free shots at her,
but you know,
all that aside,
you know,
misguided,
non scientific approach to vaccines on the side.
See her personality is great.
She's great,
she's sweet.
Even have autism no more.
No.
Well now some I
don't,
you know,
I don't know what he had,
what,
how he was diagnosed.
I don't understand autism.
They don't understand that she was pissed about Jim Carrey.
We don't call it a kid no more.
You're not sucking his dick.
And if you're not looking at this,
nothing,
no more.
Wasn't going to call the kid.
You'd have to call the kid.
Well,
you don't have to.
Why you were talking about you got different relationships and you move on.
You know,
what are you going to do?
And it's why it's a,
if maybe if he called the kid,
then Jenny get on the phone and say,
Jim,
when can I suck your Dick Again?
And he would avoid it.
You don't know.
You don't know what's going on.
But the kids still like,
what do we give a shit?
What are we TMZ over here?
I just,
she's nice.
She's pretty.
She's got a child.
She's beautiful.
She's got banging.
Tetsy what's baby good to see everybody.
Red Band in the house.
My main man.
What is that photo that you put up?
Oh,
it's a picture of her new show.
Jennifer kept McCarthy's new show and Tiffany Haddish in it also.
So Bell.
That's Paula Bell.
All right,
Paul.
Paul bells fucking whole sequence or something dirty.
And what do they do?
They do something at night?
Um,
Shit.
I don't know what that is.
It red band.
I got a call her dirty,
sexy,
funny.
It's a TV show.
It's a view panel list kind of thing.
I guess Paul A.
Bell is a fucking hilarious comments.
She's a monster.
She sees the lane.
She's at that point where she's,
she gets on the stage and she just fucking kills him.
She's become a guide.
That's why.
Yeah,
she's got the mentality like a guy,
like when you talk,
like sometimes I tweet and she'll tweet shit back at me.
Jam.
Paul also like wash your pussy and she'll tell me,
wash my dick.
You know?
So when you have that mental,
once you've gone through everything in La,
you suck the Cox.
I'm not saying she's a cock sucker,
I'm just saying that once you suck the cock,
you've taken the lunches,
you grow and you grow as a standup and one day you go,
you know what?
This guy,
nothing to do with what I got to do.
I'm just going to rock every fucking state.
And that's what she does.
Well,
she's just,
she just knows the,
that she's really funny.
She's really fun,
always working,
always see on the airport.
And I was complaining,
always friendly,
you know,
very sweet.
I really got,
it's always,
you know,
there's some nights I go out to do comedy and you bump into 18 douche bags and
you go,
you do your set and you get in your car and you come home and there's some
nights that you go out and you see people,
you haven't seen the,
you hug.
If you have a fucking,
you know,
you go outside to smoke a number and you go home and you're like,
that was fucking great.
You know that these guys are still doing comedy.
They're on some other circuit.
Like last night I saw more curvy,
you know,
every time I see Mark Curry it's 15 minutes about the store and he makes me
laugh.
He genuinely makes on,
I bumped into him at Ralphs and that's how the whole relationship,
so I said he's a great guy.
I have in the valley called flap is,
Nah,
you're just trying to do comedy.
You just want to get up and do spots.
You've already had the TV show.
He's on another TV show as it really family with Chachi.
He's one of the guys in that.
Scott Bales got a show.
I'm like,
you know,
Nickelodeon and nick at night or something,
he's plays one of the black guys on the show.
Oh really?
Yeah,
but that,
hey,
listen here,
he showed me off the air for 20 fucking years.
He's a very underrated,
oh,
he's on fire,
Bro.
Area underrated how he writes a joke now that he listens to his joke and his
earphones and he walks to these clubs and he sees ways to make the joke better
in his head while he's listened to a very,
you know,
like you listen to yourself sometimes and I turned it off and fucking want to do
heroin.
Shut that off.
Oh,
I'm so sorry.
Sorry.
Um,
I,
uh,
I recorded all my sets and I listened to most of them unless I didn't have to,
like I knew what,
what,
what trends.
By listening to them taking a chance and every time I do,
I get that much stronger.
Yeah.
Every time I watch a video,
I get that much strong.
It's like watching game tape.
Yeah.
You got to analyze yourself.
Got To analyze yourself.
I just can't,
if you look like me,
you don't want to look at yourself.
I don't want to hear my fucking voice,
you know?
It's very hard for me to go to a movie that I'm in.
I want fucking cringe when my role comes on or something.
I don't like that stuff.
There's people that are great with it.
I just don't,
I don't want to hear my fucking voice when I'm hearing what I'm hearing my tapes
from the night,
like when I go to laugh at,
when you go to the ice house,
they always give you a set from before.
When I fucking put that on at the house or something,
I get sick to my fucking stomach.
You know,
I don't focus on the material I'm focusing on May look at the size of my fucking
head.
You're the size of my stomach fucking nose and that.
Well that's what we,
we hide from a lot of times,
but I do know that if you do it,
you just become that much better.
It's like watching game tape,
you know?
It's like really watching game tape.
And I'll tell you when it gets really interesting when you do a weekend at a
club,
but you do Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday,
Minneapolis and your tape all three nights.
That's very interesting to watch it when you leave that to see how you evolve or
three nights and mannerisms you made don't what mannerisms you want to take off.
And especially for a new bit.
Yeah.
And it's amazing what habits we get that you try to break.
You know?
Like I always say,
do you know what I'm saying?
And that's a fucking ugly habit.
And I don't even know I'm saying it,
but I'm saying a lot of people say like,
like so it's very rough.
When you listened to yourself,
you see these little nuances that you're like,
God damn,
I didn't hear myself say that.
You know when people should listen to themselves,
the Moses,
when they say fuck too much,
they don't realize you see it all the time.
I said,
well,
the fee,
but the extra fucks they extra fucks where it's like this fucking guy with his
fucking thing with the fucking when you do that.
But when you do that takes away from the word.
The word doesn't mean anything.
He just wanted to fuck you crush the,
the,
the power of it because you have overused it.
Like that was something they taught me in Boston.
That was a big,
big thing and bossy and breaking the Fuck Meta.
He's breaking up.
Fuck Meta.
It's uh,
it's really wild.
When you were in Denver,
when you were coming up and not there,
nothing that,
nothing,
no art to it know,
like,
no.
Well that hadn't been Matt woods that wrote for Roseanne and a and a bunch of
the guys.
And he did something on Tuesday nights before the open mic.
You know,
it's really weird what happened with him and I,
he liked,
he was from Long Island and the first night I ever got on stage,
he was,
you know,
the comedy works doesn't open Mike on Tuesday.
And then the last guys are real headlines,
does 45 minutes.
And my first time on stage,
June 18th,
1993 he was the headliner.
I had never seen a live standup show before.
And I went and I,
that's the night I knew I was going to get onstage.
I went with my ex wife and we went and I got on stage and he was the headliner.
So he came up to me right after when he goes,
dog here,
we don't stick with this.
You're crazy.
He goes,
you got to write,
but you can,
as you've got 60% down,
you've got the presence down.
And that's part of it.
He goes,
you got to right.
So we became friends,
you know,
and I would go and then one day I got a call,
like two years later he started a writing thing before the open Mike.
Well,
I was really fucked up then.
I used to work at the sports betting service and I'd have to take a bus from
boulder to Denver and I'd go pick up an eight ball and then called the club and
cancel.
I'm not going to fucking Denver by bus when I got an eight ball at home.
And sometimes I would do it,
but literally I had something.
And after a couple months,
one day he came up to me,
he's like,
let me ask you,
I had a t shirt on,
I had a white t shirt on it.
He came up and it was,
can I talk to him about something?
He goes,
listen man,
you come here,
obviously you don't give a fuck.
He cause he funny,
funniest motherfucker.
Hey,
without even trying.
He goes,
could you imagine if he wrote,
he goes,
half the time you cancel and you don't go to my classes.
He goes,
why do you do this?
And Go,
I was going to punch this guy in the fucking mouth.
You don't want somebody who's like calling you out.
You're like,
what the fuck did I do to deserve this?
I could see if I said something,
but he kept going.
He was like,
you know,
you shouldn't even come here no more.
You are really talented,
but you're wasting your time.
I know you're doing wake up calls it huge.
I left there with my hands clenched and I walked to the bus stop and I walked
back to clobber and I never wanted to see him again.
Never wanted to see him again.
But those words sank inside of me.
I didn't even go home and do the coke that night.
He depresses me so much because he was right when somebody is right,
you can't raise your hand to them.
Sometimes you get mad,
but you're like the motherfuckers right.
And at least he had the balls to not call me out.
And for 20 people,
he pulled me aside and said these things,
he's from long island.
He knew how to do it and he just read me the riot act.
So I never see him again.
I moved to La and I'm trying to get into a room.
Do you know the first 90 days like getting out of Rehab when you moved to La,
you've got to get up.
You've got nothing happens at the couch.
You've got to get out libraries,
coffee shops,
you know the Spanish rooms.
And one night I finally,
Rudy wouldn't return my calls.
That's how I met Rudy Mourinho.
He wouldn't return my calls.
I should fuck it.
I'm going down there,
you know,
wash bro.
I'm old school comic.
You're not remember returning my calls.
I'm going down there.
The Spanish room.
I'm Spanish.
What the fuck?
I walk in and really sees me cause I go up and I had to follow that guy that
used to be the detective and don't like my women.
How I like my coffee.
Dwight's Carlos as,
no,
not a lot.
Is Rocky.
The guy in the,
in the late eighties and nineties that would go on stage with detective jacket
and a hat.
He would do the Improv when he would play that,
that stick from the,
I went to my office,
I smoked a cigarette was what was his name.
So I'm like,
God,
I'm there red band and I got to follow this fucking monster.
He had been on all the evening at the Improv,
all those shows.
But you could tell he was getting old.
The Rudy had him down at,
I grew up on fucking stage and I ripped that room apart.
You know,
like when you're fired up about something,
you're mad.
Seven minutes.
I went up to caught the wave.
Just that room apart,
followed that guy like he was buddy.
You know when you get warm,
got knife and you stick it in a Carvel cake and it goes right the fuck drew.
It was just,
I just Heister that room when I got off stage.
Who Do you think was there?
Matt Woods in the back with Brian Dunkelman.
You guys.
Brian Duncan.
He was on the first season of American idol and then he blew it.
They gave him $3 million and he fucking told,
what's his name,
the suck his dick.
So now he's,
he's doing the American idol and the Casino and some Indian casino,
but he was there with him.
Matt Woods,
the guy who told me off with,
told me to get my life together and sort of hold those things to me.
So when I walked off,
I saw him,
the Guy Tommy Sledge,
that was him.
I had a follow Tommy Sledge.
So when I get off stage,
Matt Woods sees me.
I killed and I walked up to him and I go,
Bro,
you have no idea how close you came to dying that night.
And he goes,
I know I could see it in your eyes,
but it did something to it.
And ever since that time we became tight friends.
Well,
I lost my communication about five years ago.
His brother got sick in New Mexico and we lost numbers.
But I always look on my Facebook because that guy sent me straight about common.
He pushed my buttons so much,
Bro.
In those days I was so fucked up,
I would've killed him.
Seriously.
I would have fucked him up,
but he wasn't lying to me.
Right.
Every time I want to punch him,
I'm like,
he's not lying.
He's not fucking line.
So if Matt Woods is listening,
when they really knows how they got woods telling to thank you for making me a
fucking man,
that's what he's good people can tell you things that wake you up,
changes.
Yada.
Didn't raise my hand for that guy.
Thank God I wouldn't have been the same fucking person.
Thank God.
Yeah,
no kidding.
Right.
I had a guy tell me that I started out really good,
but now I kind of dwindled off and I realized he was right.
He was another comic.
Uh,
I believe his name is Jonathan McGuire.
He's a real nice guy.
He was one of the guys we all started out with together.
There was a whole group of us,
uh,
in Boston and about six months in Maryland I was still fighting and I was kinda
like half ass in comedy,
you know.
And he said that we were all like waiting in line to sign up for us,
open Mike night.
But he's just matter of factly about it.
It's like you started off really good but you just kind of dwindled off and I
just sat there.
I didn't even respond to them.
I just sat there and I immediately was like,
shit,
he's right.
He's right.
Say something.
It's my friends,
so I never got angry at him.
He just was right.
I mean,
he wasn't even saying it to be mean.
He wasn't a dick at all.
He was just kind of being honest.
He's like,
you started off really good with any kind of whittled off.
I was like,
fuck,
I did and so then I realize like I got to quit fighting.
I got to quit martial arts.
I got to,
I can't just half this.
If I'm going to try
to be a comedian,
I can't try to do two things at the same time.
It's too hard.
That guy was like one of the main reasons why I made that choice,
that that experience where I knew I was just confronted with undeniable truth.
I don't think that people could do that anymore because there's a PC in those
comics still do it to each other.
It's important,
man.
Someone,
somebody tell you that bit sucks,
Dude.
That bits all fucked up.
Like what'd he say?
Like,
come on man.
The bid is like,
there's a piece of this and that bit.
I didn't even think of that.
Yeah,
I remember that.
This part of that,
that's this guy's thing.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Fuck.
That happens.
Like you got to have a guy come up to you and tell you like you might be on,
you might forget.
Like I had a buddy of mine forgot that he had heard a joke and then started
repeating it and then I said to this Dennis Miller's joke,
it's like shit.
You could see in his face like,
fuck,
if someone's not there for you to tell you that bid socks,
so that bit stolen or that bit's hack,
you might accidentally fuck up.
It's possible.
You know you need,
you need guys to be able to tell you no,
I'm very happy that Matt,
which called me out that night.
It was,
I still remember going there with a fucking future it onto the comedy works.
It was one of the best clubs in the country.
Tuesday night,
this 200 people middle watching open mic.
I'd go up there and kill just by talking three minutes because it's Denver.
Just my accent kills.
Just the accent kills.
Just me going up there.
Just talking about the Broncos being friendly and being friendly kills,
you know,
it's just,
uh,
it really was a,
he really and,
and him and all those guys.
Matt Woods,
Matt Berry,
Matt Barry ended up selling like six shows to NBC.
Big Time writers still around.
Well,
it's also important for someone to cut you down to size because when you're
starting out you have a really distorted perception of how good you are.
You think you're way better than you really are.
Well,
that's what the comedy for that was.
That's what the comedy store,
original rooms for the comedy store,
original room.
I love going in on a Sunday.
When you come back from someone,
you just kill for four days,
his shit and you're like,
watch this bitch and you go up there and often happen.
Nothing,
nothing.
And you'll eat dick.
I just destroyed it.
Minneapolis for three nights and here I am on a Sunday night die and unfair
during the early show,
like the seven and nine where you would see that on Sunday nights especially
cause guys would do weekend somewhere else and do really well and come in and
just get humbled.
It is really the devil's room man.
Devil's room.
He'd make you sell your soul.
That's how he make you sell your soul,
but he was seeing your bomb in there.
It was good for both of us as a transitionary period,
but that type of room,
like especially high conflict,
no crowd control,
that becomes like you develop a more hostile style.
Then it's kind of necessary because of that.
Sometimes that can be really funny.
You know both of us,
I think a lot of our style develop because of the hostility of that room I have,
I am thankful.
I am thankful because one night I got a call maybe eight years ago and it was a
Thursday night in Houston,
a Wednesday night and Houston,
they had maybe 20 people in the audience and Johnny Sanchez fucking destroyed
the room,
destroyed
the room.
To the point where Pete called me drunk and he goes,
I saw something tonight.
I only saw two people do.
He goes,
well,
you could.
Every one of my Wednesdays is dead.
The eye line is bomb.
There's only two people.
There was only one who could kill with 20 people in the room.
That was you two I saw Johnny Sanchez.
Johnny Sanchez called me the next day and said that to me.
He goes,
it's really hard to believe that people don't do this.
We do this every night at the comedy store.
Yeah.
What we did every night at the fucking comedy store,
eight people,
cause I went up at 1245 bro.
You know,
there's eight people and they've already heard every premise,
every joke,
every fucking newsline.
So you have to go up there and just come out,
you know?
Yeah.
You got to come out like John Jones on the fucking floor come.
That crawling
big part of why Kennison became Kennison Tennyson was the cleanup batter.
Kennison would go on at like one o'clock or 12 o'clock at night depending on,
you know,
whatever night was,
he was like the Kinison spot was the late spot at night and you know,
all these different comics had worked out already.
The audience,
you could start an audience at the comedy store at eight o'clock you could sit
down at eight o'clock and stay there till two o'clock in the morning.
Nobody kicks you out.
The show just keeps going.
So Kennison would go up after who knows how many hours and hours and hours of
premises is setups and punchlines and he would,
yeah.
Oh,
reset the whole room.
I love it.
I was married for two fucking years.
Hell will be like club med.
This is fat and fucking sweaty with an overcoat on like everything was off.
He had sneakers on and a t shirt with an overcoat and it was like,
what is this guy doing?
What's the flux going on in here?
Screaming with the power of a preacher with a head injury when he was a preacher
with a head injury.
Greatest comic of all time
came out of a head injury.
Is that what it was?
Yeah.
You ever read his book?
Brian actually gave it to me.
I already have it.
Brian gave it to me for Christmas.
It's out there in the,
in the front it's called brother Sam.
Yeah,
Joey actually once I read it,
I read it all to me in Seattle.
I haven't read it since [inaudible] 95 when they used to.
That's the one when they talk about Houston walking down to a bar and then they
would talk about going to the comedy store and eat and the condiments
and my brother Sam is the cherries and the brother wrote it.
A big,
big part of it that keeps sticking with me was that he was like this really
normal quiet kind of kid and then he got hit in the head.
He got like hit by a car and he got really fucked up and when he recovered he
became this reckless fucking maniac.
He became Kennison.
So you know,
a big part of what made him so amazing might have been an accident.
Like that happens sometimes.
Like there was a story recently about a guy who got hit in the head.
He had some sort of a head injury and then he came out of it and he could play
music.
Like there's weird things that happen sometimes with
the school,
with a girl that had it injury and the,
she got huge
tits and I'm not trying to be funny.
I wish I was lying to you.
This chick was flat chest with his fuck.
Got a head injury her freshman year.
By the time she was a junior hood Titsworth fucking ginormous and should become
like this sex fucking crazy chick.
Like I went to grammar school with her.
I knew she wasn't a sex fiend and a,
I bumped into like when she was a senior and she was fucking nuts.
I was a junior.
I was like,
Jesus,
why he fucking tits and just wanting to fuck.
Just,
just,
you know,
like if this guy doesn't fuck me,
y'all gonna fuck me.
And I'm like,
ah.
I don't think,
think it was not that you said that.
She's on Facebook and now she won't talk to me.
Now.
She made up,
I,
my buddy of mine bumped into her and she goes,
I don't talk to that motherfucker.
Listen,
talk to me.
Because she wasn't,
you wouldn't fuck her.
I don't know what it was.
And I,
and I had in the freshmen,
that's the girl I got left back over.
Oh Wow.
In the seventh grade for meeting a pussy and shit like that.
She wouldn't let me bang her.
I just dry hump and suck the teddies and stuff like that.
Then she had a head injury when she was a freshman.
I was a single stop.
Brian,
an eighth grader,
teenager credits,
musical talent to head injury.
We'll play this cause it's pretty crazy shit.
That's amazing.
So she became a free from a head injury and injury.
I'm not shocked man.
You know,
we had a guy on the podcast,
Dr. Mark Gordon,
who is a specialist in traumatic brain injuries,
dealt with soldiers and athletes and all these different people.
And you know,
he,
the way he talks about it,
man,
it makes you really fucking question how smart it is to get hit in the head on a
regular basis because when this guy starts talking to me about what can happen,
like he was talking about like water skiing,
water scheme that jumping up and down on water skis can fuck your brain up,
give you brain damage because your brain is sloshing around inside your skull.
I never even thought of that.
He was like,
it wouldn't even be a concussion.
Like you would be damaging your brain by just your brain sloshing inside like
headbanging.
Like there might be a reason why headbangers are so fucking goofy.
One of the reasons where they by mistake and your offer a death in the shower
coming up that handle with the salt.
Like I banged my head one time that I was off for two fucking days.
I was off.
I was a,
what do I mean by off?
I didn't get voices or just didn't feel,
you feel me.
You know what?
I got a concussion my freshman year playing football.
Think about it now.
Yeah,
I felt a little off for a few days.
You're not yourself.
Well,
you know Ryan Parsons,
Ryan Parsons got hit in the head with a golf ball and he told me he wasn't the
same for six months.
He said he got hit with a line drive,
cracked him right in the head.
He said he went down like a meteor came from this guy.
I mean,
he hit him right in the fucking head,
like really bad.
That's a dangerous thing.
A golf ball to the fucking head.
Like people think that's funny.
You're laughing at you.
Have you like Ryan and you're laughing.
I like them because we'll get to at night with a guy who was playing golf,
playing golf.
He's playing golf.
Oh No,
fuck you don't be playing fucking golf.
Easy to cop and a headgear.
Did you go,
did you hear about the foreign accent syndrome where the woman
just turned into like a Japanese lady and she's never even heard of?
Well,
she speaks with an accent.
They know no one's ever learned to an actual language.
Yeah,
she just took some guy,
Ritchie Dick.
He fucked her English.
You fuck the ring?
It was you put a gun in their mouth.
Shut.
Chip Teleo their findings for the first time.
What is this here?
I want to see that kid.
Let's play that video that I asked to pull out.
The kid is a fascinating story because he got hit in the head and he credits
that to his musical talent.
A brain injury.
Not that you should go fucking hitting your head.
You know?
It's not always you become a comedic genius or a musical genius.
Poly.
Somebody who's got a buddy at home.
Are you ready?
It may with them.
Yeah,
I suck at comedy.
Come on.
You're going to hit me in the fucking head and I'm going to get better,
bro.
Some,
some guys with head injuries are funny.
You just had it up.
Yeah,
it's not playing right.
God dammit.
I forgot to bring that new laptop.
Please remind me
our laptops.
Oldest Fuck
No.
Every day we find that more and more things about brains and especially with the
NFL and the guy shooting himself and what's going on it.
Listen,
man,
I think that you're right.
I think that you had that you have the magic,
you don't know how many hits it's going to take.
Nobody knows.
Nobody knows how many times you do this until one time you hit the right thing.
Right.
And when people get knocked out,
what happens after that?
They got knocked out all the time.
Right?
Does that happen?
Depending upon how much time you give it.
The only person that I've seen recover from a brutal knockout and retain his
chin,
his Bisbing Bisbing got knocked out by Henderson,
is one of the worst knockouts ever,
but hasn't been stopped since,
except for one time against Vitor Belfort.
And it was a head kick.
I mean,
everybody gets stopped by that kick,
the kick that hit [inaudible].
If you're a fucking human being and he had kicks you with that Shin to the head,
most likely they're going to,
you're going to go down at least.
And that's what happened at Biz Bang.
He went down and he wasn't even unconscious.
He got Tko.
The referee stopped the fight and you know,
he didn't object.
It was a good stoppage.
But the point is he didn't lose his chin from that one knockout.
It's Chin's still pretty solid.
He's been hit real hard.
Just that one knockout by vittores.
The only other one I have PTSD.
I'm sure you do.
What are you talking about you?
I know you do.
Just by hearing your stories all through our friendship.
I know for a fact
that some nights I laid down and I'll think of something and I'll think about
the worst case scenario and I'll say,
why did that pop into my head?
What?
What is that reasoning?
Why did that pop into my fucking head?
And then I think about early on in my life,
those first fucking 15 years was just brutal,
brutal.
You know,
my mom said that the first three years after my dad died,
every time I go would open,
I would turn around just to see if it was my dad,
you know,
that has to stay with you,
rusty alive.
Then my boy is dying.
You know Dominic's brushy out and Anthony and my mother dying all at one shot.
So you finding your mother.
I always know that when I see somebody like Anthony,
I saw at 6:30 AM six 30 at night.
Dawg,
you want to come over and eat?
Nah,
my mom made it.
Cool.
You want me to come over after dinner?
Nah,
I got to do homework and shit.
I'll see you tomorrow at school and then he went home.
His mother had no milk.
He got in the car with his brother,
went to a supermarket and some guy ran a red light drunk.
Boom kills.
I go to school next day.
Where's Anthony?
You didn't hit what happened though?
What happened?
He died last night.
How can he die?
I was with him until six 30 what did he do from six 30 at night?
That we were fucking in the eighth grade.
What'd you do?
Go to a disco.
So I know for a fact sometimes,
and I haven't gotten to talk to anybody,
but I started getting this.
I started getting a little stronger last four years maybe because I'm off the
blow.
Maybe because I'm off the blow now.
It's coming to haunt me a little bit differently.
It doesn't affect me in my everyday life.
It affects me in different situations.
Like with my daughter,
like when Terry drives with my daughter,
I get nervous,
I get nervous with my friends.
I get nervous about my friends a lot pro a lot because I know what it is to lose
tight friend.
I know that you can't recover from that.
You know,
we're very fortunate that we all have each other.
So I know that this Ptsd Abbott at some levels,
you know when I hear a gun fire I fucking go crazy.
Even on TV,
like sometimes I think about what these kids go through when you were in a
school,
you can't imagine guys being 12 and being at a school and some guy comes in with
one of these new fucking the age guns,
you know,
you go hunting,
you know the shotgun sounds like,
you know the 45 and sounds like you think of these new m 16 is that they come
in,
keep those fucking clicks and those texts,
you hear the bullets going in.
All that shit affects me.
Even on TV,
Bro.
Even on fucking TV when I watch it,
I got to like,
I don't want to watch this shit that you called me and told me you were going to
the movies.
And I was like,
don't go see that fucking movie Wall Street.
That was too crazy for me.
But it goes to show you what I really want to talk to you about.
How crazy where the 80s that's not exaggerate.
The eighties were insane.
That's not exactly what,
especially with cocaine.
And I think that was all the nineties actually because I think 87 was when the
big crash was it.
He says when he started working,
that's,
that was his first day in the office still fueling mother fuckers.
November 18th at 87 something.
It was around that when we crashed November 8th,
November 10th.
You know how I know I got kidnapped the guy a week later.
Real.
Yeah.
I kidnapped the grand 87.
Yeah,
getting that.
So I remember living in newspapers.
I remember,
uh,
that,
but the 80s when I went to see that movie and they saw the blow,
like my heart stopped a couple times,
but by the 20 minute mark when I went to see that,
when I look to set up more with the Lemley,
I saw it for white people walk,
run out of there like Jenny,
how about when he was blowing coke in her asshole?
I'm harassed.
That is raw.
But then was that,
that was it in her ass on his blog when they're young and I was watching Boogie
nights when they go over.
That's my favorite scene.
And a lot of movies.
Which one would mark Walberg and the guy go to the guy's house.
The guy fired man too.
And the Chinese guy with the firecracker dog,
you know what I mean?
Houses.
I went
to three in the morning that will like that.
Really?
Like,
just like you walk in and you're like,
something May,
right.
We went to one in Arizona or something.
Yeah.
You remember that?
Those parties.
They'll walk in and you're like,
you know when something ain't right and something's going to go down at this
house waiting for Vampires fucking blow and led to spray for the ceiling.
Like the opening scene in blade.
It's fucking crazy.
That's a lot of it is that amphetamine,
cocaine uppers sort of party scene.
It's very sketchy.
Like if you're,
you're going and meeting some people that are involved in that world.
You don't even know it like you think,
you think they just how I see it seems like a nice guy.
We were in Phoenix.
I didn't even know that everyone was on coke until Brian pointed out.
Me and Brian were hanging.
I'd never done coke.
I know what,
when people are kind of being speedy,
I kind of guessed that they're on coke.
But since I've never done it,
I don't,
I don't know the actual full patois.
So yeah,
I can tell if someone's high.
I can tell if someone's drunk.
Cause I've been hiding,
I've been drunk.
The cook things like a guest,
just a guest from me.
But we were in this club and Brian Goes,
you know,
everyone here is on coke.
And I was like,
everyone,
he's like,
everyone's on coke.
Everybody look around,
everyone touching their dose.
He goes in,
they were all like planning businesses look around and they were,
they were all touching each other's nose.
They're like,
Geez,
I'm fucking totally into that man.
We can show that shit through my company.
Or you're a company and they're jacked up making plans that will never take
money.
I remember him in the morning.
Yeah.
It's fascinating thing,
you know.
And that's the other thing on top of all the deaths I saw and all that.
Then you got 25 years of fucking heavy duty powder.
Yeah.
You know,
and like I told you guys towards the end,
the last three years,
I knew it was time to stop snoring at night when my spine would start fucking
hurt.
And that was the bottom of my spine would start hurting.
And I feel like little firecrackers going off like little electronic pop,
pop,
pop up.
My Bow,
I knew it was time to quit right then and there.
Wow.
That's crazy.
They lecturer,
you know,
it's funny how I always wanted to write a book about my life.
I don't want to write a book about my life and mom,
I want to write a book about the 26 year listening should be,
you'd be crazy to write a book.
This is what you should do,
what you should do.
If you want to do a story in your life,
you do a story where a guy puts a fucking camera in front of you and you start
talking to lose.
You talking loses 90% of the entertainment value of anything you say you're,
you're a master talker.
You,
you,
when you talk,
it's,
it's entertaining.
It's beautiful to listen to.
Why would you want to limit that to the printed word?
That's the last thing you want to do.
You want to make an audio book at the very least,
but more likely you want to look at your face.
He'd want to do a video,
maybe an audio book with a video companion to it,
but don't write it.
Bark too much would be missing.
You're too,
you're too,
it's like that.
That form of expression.
It's too limited for you.
It's not that it's not,
you know that you couldn't write a book and wouldn't be interesting.
I'm sure it'd be interesting,
but a big part of your genius is your relaying of information like you who's
listening to you and you because of the fact that you grew up in this really
fucked up way because the fact that you grew up with all this loss in this like
extreme,
like extreme desire for friendship and extreme loyalty to your friends like you.
One of the things that I love about you is the same thing that I strive for
myself is to be extremely loyal to my friends.
And that's,
that's who you are.
That's what you got.
But all that comes into play like the,
the immediacy and the importance.
When you're talking to people,
like there's a vulnerability,
there's a lot of shit going on that you're just going to miss in the print.
You know,
I'm not trying to blow smoke up your ass straight,
not the first guy that said,
fuck a book.
You just talk,
you just talk.
You're,
you're,
you know,
you're the funniest guy on the planet when it comes to just talking and telling
stories.
It's just weird that you know,
you,
uh,
I was,
I went to Minneapolis and the guy was clean and we were talking in between shows
about coke stories and we're both looking at each other like fucking crazy shit
at that made you do like 30 years of my life.
26 years of my life was focused around that.
Like my thoughts at one part of the day we're like,
where am I going to do it tonight?
Or not like the same way people think about eating and I'm not glamorizing it on
a style judging it.
It's something that I want to just a,
it's scary.
It's ugly.
Like when I think about,
I'm like,
God damn the people I bumped into,
the women I bumped into,
it was like,
well,
especially east coast,
right?
And if I was selling my soul,
you know,
they were fucking definitely selling that fucking soul,
in a huge way.
The things they would,
I mean,
it was just a,
it's really fucking interesting where you live.
And that's for any addiction,
Joe.
That's the fucking,
those pills,
you know,
which is really destroying us.
It's the pills.
It's not the fucking math that on Tennessee,
not us,
but it's the fucking doctors and these fucking prescriptions,
you know,
in Hollywood,
everybody is on the fucking prescription.
You do know that everybody,
90% of the I'll fucking prescriptions for something.
Even if he go to Aa and [inaudible].
And I know what in Hollywood,
I shouldn't say to the AIA as a whole,
but I know people in the Hollywood,
they'll look me in the face and go,
I'm clean and sober from alcohol,
but I'm taking pills.
The doctor gave me so I don't kill somebody for don't do this.
So don't do that too.
I sleep at night.
So I mean,
yeah.
And you know,
you go to their house,
look at 19 fucking pills.
What's the fucking difference,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
You,
did you listen to podcast yesterday with war machine?
No,
no,
no.
It's anxiety too.
And I takes Lexapro because of it.
But he's clean and sober.
Other than that.
And what'd he say about the Lexapro helps them,
helps them.
Uh,
you know,
he,
he did a year in solitary.
Oh.
Then when they put him in jail in Nevada,
they found out he was an MMA fighter and a,
they decided to remove him from general population for everybody's safety.
And he's got a fucking grenade tattooed on his neck and the kids built like a
pit bull,
you know,
so they're like,
fuck this guy.
He's not beating up any guards or whatever he's planning on,
you know,
let's,
let's put them in solitary.
So they just decided to put them in solitary for a whole year.
Crazy story,
but fucked him up.
It was already fucked up going in.
And they took him off the Lexapro when he got in.
Crazy story.
So he's going through withdrawals because he's been on this stuff,
and I don't know how Lexapro works,
but I'm assuming you probably have to wean yourself off from it
now don't they let you bring that in if you're in prison some places,
but not in Nevada.
They let them bring it in.
In California,
if he was arrested in California,
they'd let him bring it in and they would take it.
He would go to the prison doctor and they would give him his medicine but not in
Vida,
in Nevada.
And the father was like,
fuck you,
you're a criminal.
We're barely gonna keep you alive.
We're not going to give you shit.
He could sue.
Maybe.
I Dunno.
Maybe
it's a,
it should need it.
It's like a religion.
Yeah.
You know,
if you go to jail and you're a Muslim,
you need vegetarian fucking meals.
They don't give you that Muslim diet.
You could sue them.
It's part of your fucking religion is going to do it all the fucking time.
That the case,
like if they're serving pork chops and if you're a Muslim,
they want,
they're going to give you a fucking vege Italian.
I'm Muslim fucking dish man present.
Have a special fucking deal for you.
So have you.
All right.
I have sleep apnea.
I got to fucking county jail.
Okay.
Alright.
He killed somebody.
Whatever he lit the house on fire still got fucking,
this is one of the only countries you have rights as a the accused as the
accused.
You have rights in this country.
Tons of fucking writes.
A lot of people don't know about,
so I go to La county the next fucking day.
After the first night,
my attorney goes down and says,
guys,
either he needs to get transferred to a hospital for a sleep apnea.
We need to bring the machine and they're going to go,
Nah,
we can't bring the machine.
And it could be a blog bombing there.
They've got to transmit to a hot flash.
It takes three or four fucking days.
My blood pressure goes up.
I got a heart attack.
Guess who's getting the suit?
Can you imagine that?
Does that how it works or would you just deal with it?
But he will know.
How can you deal with it?
You have a fucking,
you know,
let's say you,
I know if you have a mental health issue,
you break a window.
You know there are people who take,
don't take their medication,
they break a window.
It take you into jail.
You want these people in here without that fucking medication.
Same thing applies.
Anxieties is fucking silent killer for some people.
It's not at that.
I was never at that point for me,
but I know people that I've,
I've spoken with that it's a fucking,
they can't be in certain situations.
Wow.
Because it's just mind boggling form.
Can you imagine being in solitary,
being in a room like this?
No air conditioning,
no windows.
That does shit to you.
Sometimes when I work out and I can't breathe and there's no doors opening the
gym,
I get fucking anxiety just cause I want to go out and just get out.
Just kind of have for five minutes just breathing the air.
I'm back just being cooped up in a corner doing fucking that lifts at the
fucking,
the kettle bell thing.
Sometimes I got to walk through the door.
Sometimes I make them open up the garage door.
I get anxiety just from being in that position,
so I can't imagine what he did in an eight by six hours.
I'm very year for a year.
I big as the fucking salary by the tiny and they give me shit and okay,
I know you were at home going,
Joey,
but he's a criminal.
I understand that in this country,
the criminals,
the fucking,
I don't care.
Even the world trade fucking bomb.
Sammy the bull Gravano they were all under that fucking jail in Colorado
Tomahawk.
Whatever it is,
they got rights they got right.
You gotta give him that medication.
You got to give him this.
Otherwise,
yeah,
you're
torturing them.
I mean the idea of punishing people for something,
it's very strange because
the idea is that you're going to take some person,
you get to put them in jail for the rest of their life and make them like feel
terrible and be just Moan and rot away.
It's very like medieval and archaic,
but they couldn't be,
they couldn't be a productive member of society.
Yeah.
Jails are not bad.
I'm not going to sit here and Pam and I,
I'm a felon.
I can't vote,
which you're trying to overthrow all that should exist.
They really,
some states Obama wants to vote.
Oh,
I'm Bama wants to vote.
But it's funny because a majority of people with felonies in the country are
black.
Well who would be next?
Because it actually,
I shouldn't say Obama wants to vote because he won't be,
he won't be,
he won't be eligible.
But,
so who would be that?
They would benefit from that.
I got to pick some new black guy coming deep from the south is shit.
No,
I'm just,
but I saw that.
But public enemy coming true.
You never know.
You have a black planet baby.
It's really amazing.
Like when I went in I had to refill,
so I had trouble sleeping.
They put me on fucking,
what's that shit they put you on when you're crazy?
The thorazine,
thorazine prison.
Three weeks yet,
that's what it called thorazine.
Thorazine.
They had me on that in prison for two or three weeks because I couldn't sleep at
night.
Whoa.
So they have mis,
you know,
you have so many myths,
a misdiagnosis diagnosis in that.
Yeah.
Like they couldn't figure out something.
And I know,
you know,
like listen,
if,
uh,
if it's a tough visit,
this is a very complicated subject in our country because everybody was going to
chime in on this,
you know,
but a guy who gets in trouble has rights.
No,
it's not right that we don't put somebody who smoked pot in jail for 26 fucking
years.
But some guy who kills a fucking little girl,
a little boy lights a house on fire,
has no respect for society,
needs to get put in jail.
Maybe that'll slow them down.
We've discussed this before.
There's no rehabilitation in prison,
Bro.
There's no,
uh,
class that you take to come out and be a better person.
It's how much of this do you want to take?
How many times you know prison isn't about the food.
We goof here,
Huh?
The food or you're gonna get fucked in the shower.
That's all bullshit.
The thing that,
if you're a man,
can you imagine me coming into your room every morning kicking your bed?
How would you feel every morning if I came into your room and just put the
fucking light on at five and go Rogan,
get up,
bitch,
and kick your bed.
How many mornings before you stab me?
Legitimately,
if I would've lived with you and I,
we looked downstairs,
I came into your room every morning,
kick your fucking bed and said,
hey bitch,
get up.
How long would it take you to stab me?
What have you had an eight year sentence?
Take a lot less.
And I'm a guard.
Well,
I'm already a guard.
But what you're doing in life,
that's what makes you not want to come back to prison because it's not somebody
fucking in the ass.
It's your manhood pro with me,
it was my man.
They took my man or the way.
There's a man telling me what the fuck to do and you have to listen and you have
to listen and there's no two ways about it and they can treat you in a way that
no one else in society is allowed to be.
That guy said to you,
Joe,
you started out good,
but you teed it off.
Yeah,
we didn't get mad because it's not what you say.
It's how you say it.
Yeah.
Is another way to say that you're going to haul off and punch me in the fucking
mouth and that's how they say it.
They're always testing you.
That thing that you have in you because they know they can and that's it.
That's what makes you not want to come back.
When you look at that place and go,
I never want to be put in this position again.
Amanda is never going to talk to me and that fucking matter again,
I'll die before some motherfucker talks to me like that.
Wow.
There's two types of that.
There's some people you know,
but there's some people go in the inside like me,
you know,
how am I going to live without fucking Chinese food?
I mean these are the little things that I thought about,
but these are the decisions you make are not going back to prison and not going
to prison is a bad thing,
but people are bad fucking people and I need to get stopped in time with me.
Joe Rogan.
I need it to get stopped sometimes.
I had been doing drugs since I was 15 I was 27 years old.
It was,
it was a six month process that didn't have to do drugs.
I have to think about drugs that makes you see life a lot clear and it makes you
ask you this question.
Do you want to be in this?
Do you really want to come back?
I mean,
there's people that sit around all day talking about h block and Kansas.
You were there and Joe Rogan come on dog.
I was there.
That's the baddest place.
The pork chops are Tuesday bitches,
red band who did time in Columbus.
I was in and that proud of doing this tour that they do.
Why they plowed of doing this fucking prison tour.
I was up there.
I partied out with him one time.
What did you party out?
You were in a fucking jail south shooting heroin.
Sharon.
A fucking needle with some other guy and your party and out.
What the fuck party not is that some fucking black transvestite?
Suck your Dick.
That's a party.
Really.
So you got to remember the mentality is some of these guys,
Bro,
this is it for them.
This is it,
bro.
I got a fat chick that sends me money.
I'm straight.
They get some chick that wants a boyfriend in prison cause you know you've got a
thousand and I'm fucking dummies.
Yeah.
What's that about thousand dudes that are in prison.
That's a common thousand of those dummies.
They don't fuck that.
Don't suck.
They just bring you groceries and then like,
and then it's funny cause let's say I date you,
right?
Let's say I date this girl and she's bringing me groceries.
I'll ask her though.
You got a homie to hook up with my boy over here and she'll say,
yeah,
I got a homie for her.
She needs a boyfriend.
She'll be like 450 pounds.
She's fat.
She's a recession.
But this bitch makes like 80,000 here.
She's dying to have a boyfriend.
She goes to that jail,
she gets a boyfriend,
they take pictures together on the weekends.
It's fucking crazy.
Wow.
That's so weird.
And then not allowed conjugal visits,
right?
No.
Until then comes a time,
you know when you're short.
But I don't think they allow conjugal visits because of Boston.
I think when that guy was going to be president out of Massachusetts like 10
years ago.
Yeah,
yeah.
Teen years ago,
he got in trouble because the caucus had conjugal visits in Massachusetts and
somebody killed somebody.
So they had to stop him across the country.
I don't,
don't,
please don't.
I don't think it
was a conjugal visit.
He had a release,
like a temporary release,
like a furlough.
He could go on the weekends somewhere and he killed somebody.
Really?
Uh,
something.
I know the feds
like,
let's say you were in a loud pop or like my,
uh,
the,
the low minimum code,
minimum security places.
I know you'd come in for the weekend and fuck somebody he can,
I know you're coming in for two days.
Willie Horton,
that was the guy's name downtown Willie Horton.
I think that was his name.
Wait a minute.
Murderer.
Yeah,
it was a huge,
a huge scandal.
Right.
Cause he,
he killed somebody on a,
on a furlough.
That's what it was.
What's his name?
Willie Horton.
It is while you're working.
Yeah.
And that's,
that brought when they get out and they got some chick that's feeding them and
sending them money.
Every boat.
The other thing with Dukakis,
his wife starts tracking paint.
Remember that Shit.
Do you remember that shit?
His wife went crazy.
Was she was drinking everything.
She was drinking like a,
like antifreeze and like fucking deodorant.
She was,
she was doing,
I was just drinking Cologne.
What was she drinking?
That's like a paint thinner or some shit.
She,
uh,
she,
what was that disease called?
That's xor like no,
no,
no.
That's not what it was though.
It was her,
she was an alcoholic and she was trying to,
she was trying to brake clean and she couldn't do it and so she was trying to
take anything.
That thing where you need paint,
like lead attraction to lead,
that's not what it is.
This was a,
uh,
an alcoholism thing.
Can you do caucus?
I know the homeless people in Columbus,
Ohio used to always drink alcohol,
like rubbing alcohol.
That was their thing.
Yeah.
Well,
that's what this,
that's what she drank.
Kitty Dukakis drank that stuff.
To me.
That was a huge disaster.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
She had a huge battle with alcoholism apparently.
I don't know.
I'm fucking paint finish.
She's 30.
She's 77 years old.
She's still alive.
Oh my goodness.
Keep on rocking in the free world.
Well,
the problem,
the stress was off her after her husband disappeared from the limelight.
Like being in the limelight is like that.
We're trying to become the president.
Oh my God.
What a fucking crazy way to live your life.
No,
but every four years it's lightened up.
[inaudible] like now it's impossible.
Like now you have no social life with the cameras and the iPhones and they're,
you know,
it's crazy.
Years ago you'd get away with little things as a present.
Now they have you on every fucking level,
every step you're responsible.
You know,
every word you say is on the Internet.
the next morning after a state of address,
whatever,
they got you on every level.
It's got to be,
that's the hardest job in the world.
That and being a professional athlete in New York City.
Yeah,
yeah.
No kidding.
Right.
In New York City's brutal people fucking tore your world dog.
They will.
You have one bad game they will fucking tore mentioned.
They'll turn on you and they feel justified because they know how hard they work
and they know how much you make and they're like,
fuck cam.
They get rid of people.
I mean,
you know what?
The teams don't get rid of people in New York.
The media does basically.
Really?
Yeah.
Look what happened to Mark Sanchez from the jets.
What happened?
The media fucking got,
you know,
it was to overpower him.
Look at t t boat doing blow in Miami last week and this isn't shit.
Then they get in trouble for doing blah.
I don't know.
But look,
you know,
the,
he was a quarterback in New York.
The media fucking get you out before and it ain't even make a decision.
They have to listen to the media.
So overwhelming.
That's interesting.
And especially like a really vocal town like New York,
like they are really,
really low scores.
You're very aggressive.
Brutal.
Yankee's Yankee Games are fucking brutal.
Yeah,
they love it.
We never talked about fucking his gummy bears,
those testosterone gummy bears.
He was popping gummy bears.
Fucking hayride.
You didn't read about that.
He was taking testosterone,
gummy bears.
Gummy bears,
like in the first inning.
So He'd be on fire by the seventh inning,
Bro.
You don't,
you didn't watch 60 minutes now come on.
I thought you knew about this.
I don't know.
It was kicking shit up to a different level.
Gummy bears because I guess they piss you after the show.
They'd piss you like the UFC after the fight that after every game they despots
they piss test,
right.
And B.
How would he get away with it then?
I guess the level of go away was just,
it would just spurt,
but you got to read all this.
You gotta let me know.
You've got to fill me in on all this shit.
They would have to,
you'd have to,
he's faked it and it's all hearsay.
I mean,
the guy never got caught.
They offered him 50,000 to disappear.
I mean,
it's all fucking,
he'll say no,
I don't even know what's really going on.
I know the other guy tried to retire yesterday,
but I know a rod is coming back.
He ain't coming back bro.
They just fucking hate him.
Why?
What do you,
who's the other guy?
What did,
what is either GE or GE or GE or retiring?
You think they're related though?
Like he just knows that they can't take stuff to the Isas take anymore.
It did.
That's definitely happening.
Right.
And a lot of guys getting popped where they used to be able to protect
themselves and then guys like Maguire and you know guys who kind of came out
about it now it's like it sort of revealing the whole undercurrent.
Well why was cool that motherfucker knew that he was on,
he pulled the Joey Diaz,
he disappeared.
He fucking came back looking like,
you know,
he just disappeared.
Yeah.
Nine years.
He just,
he knew,
he didn't know.
He just does a fucking pen.
He came back and he was like my size normal person.
Oh yeah.
Hey,
it looks like a guy that works out.
But I mean,
you remember what would a gorilla he used to look like?
Oh my God,
they had these forearms.
He's Popeye forums about like a fucking,
like a horse's leg on the,
on the,
the meat of their forearm just as manly.
Remember Steve Garvey?
That motherfucker had the most ridiculous for,
I remember when we were like,
when I first started lifting weights,
when I was in wrestling,
people would talk about Steve Garvey's forearms and we would do like these
little right wrist curl things with the string.
We attached the weight to it and you'd do it like that and it burns out your,
and we will like Steve Garvey,
Steve Garvey get forums like Steve Garvey because he had these like,
they were ridiculous.
They were Popeye forearms.
Did they have pictures of it?
Yeah,
pull up Steve Garvey's forearms.
Take a picture of this shit.
He does.
It's like some guys like known for their,
their body parts and some weird way.
But Garvey was one of them and he's like all American man guy looked like he
belonged in a fucking GI.
Joe Comic book was sturdy eyebrows.
What's matter?
And he's looking very good.
One that has a good,
they don't really have this pop iron ones.
Did they show us forms in any of them?
What were you in and on about?
Do you see anything?
Oh yeah,
he was joking on talk charcoal on tech.
They uh,
when they started,
did you Google his forearms?
Okay.
Why don't you try that?
Why the fuck would you go go that bro.
You suck at Google.
All right.
Whatever.
I forgot it.
Unless you could find it.
That mother fucker had some big ass risks and he would hold that fuck the bat.
And his forearms are just ginormous.
Whose there's one picture on a page that looks like him without a helmet on,
which was usually,
yeah,
that's him in a charity game or something.
Either way.
You know the guy from the fucking Yankees,
the Yankees had this Japanese plant,
not itchy.
Rosa Zukie the one they had before him dog.
You could see that motherfucker's quadriceps to his pants.
Oh,
I bet that I used to look and go,
what the fuck is that like tool like an upside down via an upside.
Down v would be coming right down the front of his fucking legs.
You're like,
God damn pictures it.
Shit.
It's a fairly decent picture.
But you'd really have to see him swinging a bat to realize how fucking
ridiculously strong it's forearms were pretty decent though.
You could say though,
if the end,
it wasn't like bodybuilder muscle.
Yeah,
like hairy arms and shit.
He was a man,
you know?
It wasn't all shaved down lean.
He probably drank beer every night.
It just fucking,
it just had man strength.
Oh,
just crack you at that bat.
Woe.
Him and Tommy.
Oh,
sorry.
I can't,
yeah,
and Frankie's your beautiful hair too,
guys.
A man manned manly man.
Um,
how did we get on the subject of giant forums?
We're talking about someone with some,
yeah,
so the gummy bears,
he would take these fucking things like in the first inning,
in the first inning,
and the human would've had a rubber deck to guy when he would text the guys.
And the guys would text him back to the doctor,
he would say is now the right time.
The guy would text them back yet and he would fucking pop.
Oh,
I read about that.
So with that would mean is was time released.
Let's find out.
Find out what he did.
The fucking tremendous fucking tremendous door.
I thought you'd know all about it.
After you take system
with a rod gummy bears and see what comes up.
Took ped gummies and dug out.
There you go.
Hey,
Ron took p e d dummies gummies.
Wow.
Does your article is revealed by a Dr [inaudible] done a doctor did it.
Damn.
A doctor ratted them out.
So sad.
But he would admitted it.
He admitted it.
Right?
This is what I think you want me to tell you what I think,
Bro?
Look,
where's this gummy bears?
When when people,
I think the Yankees have to pay him a lot of money.
I think they don't want to pay him.
So I think a lot of this,
they went after this doctor gave him some money to tell the child because
everybody else got in trouble.
They suspended this guy for a fucking long ass time.
You don't like when people want somebody to stop doing something like John
Gotti,
the feds were going to do whatever they willing to do to get John Gotti and
throw him in fucking jail.
It didn't matter what they had to do.
Lie on the stand.
They didn't give a fuck.
This is the same thing they're doing with this guy.
What does it say that Brian,
does it say anything about how long I'm looking for how long it takes for a
test.
Positive.
So you just see if you can find that how long it takes because it'll be too
involved for,
to keep up with podcast and do it.
Um,
so they would take it.
I bet that's what it is.
I bet it takes like eight hours to get into your system or something like that
where you pee it out probably doesn't quite get into your piss track.
What he did after the game,
talked about it on 60 minutes.
What he was doing after the game.
Very interesting shit.
Now testosterone gummies to give you search for that.
So let's say there's a UFC fight.
He's going to fight on the seven o'clock card.
He's the third fight.
Yeah,
pop the fucking testosterone pill or the Gumi while the fight ahead of him is
on.
You know what's interesting man?
The argument against letting them do that is not that good.
Like he got guys like Jose Conseco,
he's fine.
He's in his 50s and he looks great.
Like that guy was the juice monster.
He was the juice monster.
I mean,
I know he's only one person.
I know.
If you want to do a real study of baseball players,
you have to look at a bunch of them that used and or abuse steroids.
But man,
I don't know.
I mean,
what's the worst thing that can happen and is it anything like the worst thing
that can happen if you play football because that's fucking legal.
It seems like the worst thing and then happened if you play football is you get
fucked up.
What's the worst thing that you have?
But if you do MMA,
obviously I support that.
The worst thing that happened,
you can get fucked up.
What's going on with these baseball players that just get bigger.
These,
it seems to just get bigger.
Like Mcguire's around.
He's not beggar anymore,
but he seems fine.
He's coaching baseball.
Sammy Sosa became a white guy.
I don't know what the fuck happened there.
What happened there?
I don't know.
Sammy Sosa,
is it like a skin condition that he says this skin condition?
I don't know.
Maybe.
Maybe bears,
well my friend who's a doctor told me that there are certain Filipinos that uh,
he treats,
uh,
not that he treats that uh,
his friend treats or someone he knows treats that take a specific supplement or
a specific drug that is designed to make your skin paler.
And it's like a common
thing that they do this here,
let me,
if I don't know why I said Filipinos,
we could,
cause he told me that the people that he knew that I had gotten it done were
Filipinos.
It says that these gummies cycle in and out of this system quickly.
Yeah.
I drug test would have to happen right soon after taking it.
Really?
Yeah.
That seems weird.
That's weird.
You know,
we evolve every fucking day.
Why don't we think drugs are going to fucking evolve?
We evolve every fucking day.
I mean,
they don't even have edibles.
No more than have capsules now that you'd take,
that will put you on a different fucking planet if you're on a diet or
something.
Now you're diabetic and Hollywood and La for fucking ta.
It's everything now.
Yeah.
This is,
let me tell you about this shit that they're doing.
This is freaky man.
These people taking this shot to lighten their body.
This is a really fucking interesting man.
Yeah.
They take a few shots of this stuff and it starts to,
this is weird.
They have pictures of people before and after they did it.
Oh my God.
It's intravenous glutathione injections.
Aw.
What the hell,
man?
They gained popularity and us and Philippines in 2007 and came to Pakistan in
the little over a year and a half ago.
Wow.
The doctor says,
my mission is to help patients battle pigmentation does a bad accident.
Right.
Is that how someone for Pakistan talks?
Maybe?
Yeah.
I could get away with it.
A couple shots.
They,
they uh,
start lightening dark spots start to fade away.
That's interesting.
Well,
whatever man,
do whatever the fuck you want to do.
What do I care?
What,
what is your argument then?
You're saying that for us,
for MMA,
well,
for MMA it's different.
This is why it's different for him in May because your main goal is to inflict
damage on people and if you have an unfair advantage and inflicting damage on
people and makes you get away with things you probably wouldn't get away with.
If you're a mere mortal,
mere mortal working with a mere mortals body,
um,
there are repercussions to hyper testosterone levels and hyper human growth
hormone levels over prolonged periods of time.
But there are also benefits of having high testosterone.
If you were the type of guy who takes way more than you're supposed to take and
does it all the time,
he wouldn't be able to do it forever.
But you could conceivably go through a strong camp doing that and you would have
an advantage.
You would have a physical advantage.
It doesn't mean you're going to win the fight because there's still skill and
technique and we'll,
and heart and courage is a lot of things that you can't measure and put.
Put a a,
you know you can't quantify them,
but when you can't quantify is that he take the same person with the same well
and the same heart,
the same desire,
and you give them steroids,
they become a bad or mother fucker.
It's just that simple.
Your body recovers faster.
When you recovers faster,
you can train harder and get more work done.
You can do things that you can't normally do,
like work three hard times in a day.
You know you could do that.
You mean there's a lot of guys who get through that shit just on sheer force of
will force their body to respond,
but there's other guys that get on the gear and they get on the gear and they
can pop through those fucking three and it's still hard work.
Don't get me wrong,
there's still putting in some fucking massive hours.
They're still busting their ass.
They're still exerting a lot of will but they get a little chemical help and
that chemical health is undeniable and part of the problem with that chemical
health when it pertains to fighting is that what we like about fighting is not
just watching an athlete perform what we like is the battle of preparation and
will and willpower and determination that allowed you to get to be that person
that standing across the octagon from that other person and knowing in your
heart of hearts that this is a 50 50 proposition and you're going to throw
yourself into the fire and try to smash this motherfucker.
There's other bad ass motherfucker that's been training just as hard as you,
perhaps just as long as you just as deadly as you are and you know how fucking
deadly you are,
but he's juiced to the gills just juiced up here and he's been working out in a
way that you haven't been able to because he's been putting in extra sessions
because he's been repairing his muscle tissue really quickly so he has more
energy.
The next day he has more cardio because he's taking EPO and blood thinners and
all those things at cyclists take,
he has more and more growth hormone is body than a normal person because he's
injecting it into his body despite the fact that he's only 26 years old.
That shit's real.
That's real.
That's real and it's happening and that's where it becomes a problem because the
purity of the,
the competition comes into question when you know that someone's received
artificial help.
I mean,
the argument is that everybody receives artificial help.
They,
they're all on it.
They all like to say that people would veto.
He just said that recently.
Everyone's using during camp.
He actually said that maybe he's right.
He obviously,
he knows more than I do.
He's in those camps.
The war,
the best I do is do a little training occasionally with guys that fight.
I'm not in their camps.
I'm not fucking doing two a days with them.
If [inaudible] says it,
you got to take that for what it's worth.
He's a world class fighter.
He's a former champion.
He's fought all over the world.
If he tells you a lot of guys are using in camp,
I have to assume he's right about,
let's say I do a camp.
How long did it's out of my system.
I do a six week camp.
It depends.
I mean,
I didn't know about these gummy bears as you say.
I'm gonna say it like that from now on.
Kumi bears.
No,
but this is just,
I don't,
I don't even know.
I'm talking about,
I go to Mike Dolce and I'm going to fight fucking Carlos conduit that first week
three.
I'm just,
I'm just saying,
I'm a one 70.
I'm a 22 year old guy.
I'm gonna fight.
Am I got a six week camp?
When do I start shooting and when do I stop?
That's a real good question.
I mean,
I don't know if you would need,
if you're 22,
the guys who probably,
you start using it,
they'd get a little older and they start using it.
It could fuck you up when you're younger.
And it's one of the reasons why some guys have gotten testosterone use
exemptions,
um,
early in their life.
Like,
even though they're young twenties because they use steroids and then their
testosterone shut down,
the production shut down and so then they might not have even tested positive
fighting.
You know?
That's also a possibility for testosterone use exemption that you've always had
it from the beginning of your martial arts career,
that you've got a doctor's note before you ever fought.
So you never cheated.
And it could be because you used steroids when you were younger.
You could have been a bodybuilder or a football player,
someone who took too much stuff and fucked up their own endocrine system.
It's super common.
So for a guy like say Chris Weidman who swears up and down that he never uses
anything,
and I believe him and I talked to everybody that he trains with and I believe
him,
I think he's just a stud athlete.
For a guy like that who doesn't take anything,
is it fair for him to fight a guy who's taken something?
I don't know.
You know,
It's,
it's an interesting question.
If the doctor say that you could,
you could take these supplements,
you can take this testosterone,
you could supplement your testosterone.
If the doctor say it's okay and you,
you allow that in a world title fight.
I almost think,
I almost think that everybody should be allowed to do it.
Almost think that everybody should be allowed to do it.
If that's going to happen,
if they're going to continue testosterone replacement,
I almost feel like it should be up to the fighter and that would be a point of
discussion when you do the commentary that uh,
you know,
he's chosen not to use testosterone and he fights with his natural testosterone
whereas this guy doesn't,
that's almost something that we should talk about like as an option because
people are rigging the system.
You're getting charismatic doctors who talked to athletic commissions and tell
of a guy who's got a medical problem.
But what they leave out is that the guideline,
I just got off of a six week steroids cycle.
So when they,
they do a test of his blood after he is clean of all of his steroids,
his testosterone is low.
It's because he just got off of it.
It's not what a normal man,
normal man,
you know,
300 500 maybe 800 they know his is like one 60 well why is his one 60 because
his body's struggling to Regaine testosterone production.
It's not because he has a sickness that you're addressing with medicine that
otherwise he wouldn't be healthy and wouldn't be able to do it.
He's,
he's done this to himself and we know they've done this to themselves.
So that's when it becomes a real issue.
Where it becomes a real issue was you're,
you're favoring people who have cheated and of course the argument for the
people that have gotten caught is like Victoria said,
hey man,
everybody's doing this.
They're all using,
I got to go with him because he's the guy that's in the trenches.
He's the guy that's,
you know,
one of the main guys at the black resilience.
If he says everybody's using,
who knows what the fuck's going on,
who knows.
If it's just maybe means a lot of people use when they get injured,
maybe means a lot of people use when they go to a doctor because they're dealing
with something specific.
Recovery from surgery,
whatever the fuck it is.
I don't know,
man.
but what does all that,
Brian,
this is supposedly what Alex Rodriguez is alleged drug rigid.
Anyone which gludethyon was on that.
What's that mean?
What's a the antioxidant.
Hgh.
EHR.
A fire on cream.
Oh Wow.
How weird.
Well,
listen man,
think about how much fucking money Alex Rodriguez made.
Throwing and catching a ball,
hitting the ball.
What did he play?
What position he play?
Outfield.
Thank you.
Pleased the outfield.
Shortstop.
Thinking about how much money that motherfucker,
man,
he was a huge star.
Huge Star.
Huge dot.
Khan's Amani fucked every bitch.
Here's the problem with these guys.
This is the only thing I have.
Yeah,
that that took defend him.
The only thing I have is that they're fucking season as long,
bro.
That's a long that it's hard to do.
That's a long ass season.
They played two games in a row.
They do double headers.
Yeah,
that's what I mean.
Four or five in a year maybe.
I don't know what to.
So how do they do that?
They start at noon or something like that.
They start at noon,
but that's not it.
I'm talking about they start and fucking,
they started playing baseball at the end of January and they go through October.
Yeah,
there's already training camp that's there and I was on it right now throwing a
ball around.
It's mid February.
So a lot of money,
man.
But hey mom,
it's a great job.
It's a great job.
The safe.
Then it's a long fucking seasons.
17 weeks.
Every fucking week.
You have one day off arrest after Sunday.
You know Sunday's like you don't want to know what you wake up feeling like I'm
Monday.
Oh yeah,
I can imagine.
You could only a manager,
a linebacker.
You feel like a fucking truck hit you.
That's what's been hit.
You gotta hit 18 times by your fucking truck.
I remember when I was on the wrestling team,
Sophomore Year of high school,
I never worked harder at anything in my entire fucking life.
I couldn't believe how sore I was just walking home every day,
you know,
we were carrying kids up fucking stairs and doing crazy drills and a lot of,
a lot of fireman's carries carrying people around the the wrestling room,
lot of fucking drills,
a lot of wrestling and then running all,
I mean it was unbelievable.
I went from no working out at all to like this unbelievable workout schedule.
I mean I think I'd done karate a little bit,
but it was bad.
It's barely a workout compare to this wrestling practice.
It was like barely nothing.
No.
Everybody line up,
so I kicked their rent is 100 degrees for the room.
You're rent is a hundred degrees.
Then you got to run stairs.
I used to play football and watch them practicing and I would die and I'd be
running sprints were like of equipment on and you're like,
I'm dying.
And you look over at them and they were on the third floor running fucking 80
times up and down and you're like,
God,
no.
Better conditioned athletes.
Then wrestlers and then after wrestlers,
mixed martial arts fighters,
mixed martial arts Fridays maybe even over wrestlers because they have more
things to do.
You know they're think about striking.
You gotta think about submissions but wrestlers set the pace.
The one of the reasons why it mixed martial arts fighters fight and compete at
such a high level is because the example shown by like real high level
wrestlers,
they just take conditioning to this whole new place.
And then I think honestly if I really be honest about it,
I think that the elite MMA players take it to another place in Thailand.
They take it to one more place cause they involve striking.
I got to tell you something,
but I've never looked at the clock and said,
I wish I could
live my life again.
But if I was 25 again,
I'd be Joe Lozano.
I wouldn't want to fight in the gym.
I would just want to do Jujitsu.
It's so fucking interesting.
What an interesting fight in the UFC.
Tournament's everyone should,
we want you to do it now.
If it's changed your life now is that which just one years old man?
You said it's changed your life now.
I love it.
I just think it's,
I love getting beat up.
I think that when you just prepares me for everything.
When I got to see for me Jujitsu some completely different than what it is for
somebody at 20.
You know,
they want to go to competitions and shifted me.
It's just getting healthy.
For me,
it's like a,
a goal.
Like when I first went,
I could do three hip escapes now I could do the whole floor and back and I got a
style,
you know,
I could do,
I can't still do any judo roles.
I mean that's great though.
Hip escape all the way up and back,
back and then the other one and then the one where your hip escape and pull your
leg back and flip around that time broke my toe and uh,
you know,
I'm learning all this shit that I've always loved Joe Lowe's on.
I've always loved the Jujitsu guys.
I Love Daddy.
I love Marcello.
I love [inaudible].
I love Jujitsu.
Once you grow a punch.
Gads fun.
A kick to the head is fun,
but the all,
when you see a really,
really good Jujitsu,
like I don't watch no shit on Youtube.
I watch videos,
music videos,
and I watched Jujitsu on Youtube.
Look at Eddie Bravo.
I'll place one 63 the kids rip.
No,
he's really working hard,
man.
He did three workouts last Wednesday.
He goes to John Jackson,
dedicated as fun.
My friends call me from John Jack and they're like,
you should.
It's already tonight,
Bro.
Yeah,
he's dead.
Like John.
John teaches a class and he's got Eddie on the side,
so he rolls.
Then he got Eddie on this side.
They say it's pretty fucking interesting to watch.
That's awesome.
I can't go to the fight.
I'm the Florida that week.
Oh yeah.
No Way.
I'm going to call me.
I can't do they sell tickets with that squad baby?
Damn.
Yeah,
it's Fort Lauderdale and I can't get to him.
I want you to be there for them.
He to,
he wanted me to.
I told him no,
I wouldn't walk down the thing with him.
He goes,
why not?
I don't remember fucking,
uh,
when Kay James walked down fucking whatever I walk in,
nobody said that ain't no fighter.
What you're looking at me like that,
you know what I'm saying?
So why you your friend,
you my bride energy.
But I swear to God I would love to be 25 just to start Jujitsu just so I could
just the camaraderie I said gotten.
How long have you been doing it now?
Since May.
I'm terrible.
Has it gotten you in better shape though?
Yeah.
Oh fuck yeah.
No gas out after like the second sparring session.
I've got stop the third minute,
but drug,
when I went,
I was gassing up the first one.
I hold my breath,
you know,
and I think,
um,
you know,
you hold your breath when you think I go Tuesdays I go to kettle bells.
Like these three weeks I've been off.
So I go to kettlebells Monday,
Wednesdays and Friday mornings.
Then I go to Jujitsu Tuesdays.
I couldn't go today cause I had to come here at three but I'll go tomorrow night
I,
it'd be going to class and then I'll do Marcello madness a little bit.
And that's fucking brutal.
What's Marcella?
50 burpees in between everything else he teaches you.
So Am I.
50 burpees,
walk,
lunges,
50 burpees,
25 push ups,
50 burpees.
I can't do that work.
That's a lot.
I can't do a bourbon.
Why so many burpees?
Because he want,
he's John Job there.
He's Brazilian.
He wants you to be really tired by the time we choose the technique.
And then you roll later on.
Well they say that the best way to really a figuring out how to fight when
you're tired is to fight when you're tired all the time.
Just do it in the gym so that you use technique and you don't use strength.
Now that's the idea behind it.
But the,
the,
the problem with that is I think that's real good mentally and psychologically.
I think that's real good.
But skill learning,
you learn skills best,
you get the SH,
the sharper 10,
you're not telling,
you're not tired.
So I think that it's probably a super important aspect to tea to training,
but the best way to do it,
it's almost definitely go through drills first.
I'm going to Reagan's most people.
I hear you man.
The 23rd I'm going to Higgins.
Yeah.
Are you?
Yeah,
I'm going to this workshop.
I love he again.
What's a Sunday and when is it?
What day?
The 23rd of this month.
Yeah.
You'll be coming back from Vegas.
Ah,
1230 down in and not Beverly hills,
but the other school and a off the ocean.
I Love Hagen.
I've never met him,
but I can say he's a really good time for him and Abu Dhabi when he's fighting.
And I will dive in 2003.
Yeah.
And uh,
I was,
uh,
I was there and he would,
call out to me like,
because he was out of shape.
It was just,
uh,
he hadn't trained at all.
He just,
he was so good that he could just like show up and,
and just start rolling with like the best guys in the world and heavyweight
divisions.
I mean,
he get,
it's just such a beast.
He's so technical and he's,
he's,
he's as old school as you get.
There's a great old video of he gun rolling with Hixon Gracie and uh,
it's like when they were both young and it's,
it's a,
it's a crazy video and the Hickson was older than Hagen,
but he can was like the dangerous up and coming cat and uh,
you know,
he would call up and he'd look at me and I have to yell out like three minutes
left,
one minute left too.
He's a big guy,
right?
He's big now.
He was like,
pull up a Hixon Gracie versus r I.
G.
A.
N Machado.
There's a video.
It's kind of cool to watch because,
um,
this video is a,
you know,
Hickson was a r r.
I.
C.
K.
Um,
this video is from like the early days,
like the 1980s or some shit when they were both young and Brazil.
And they're both,
you know,
they're growing up.
Most people in the world don't even know what you did too.
Is most of the world has no idea that Brazilian jujitsu exist and down there and
Rio are these two super alpha predators going after each other in this
incredible high level Jujitsu match.
It's submission match.
This is them going at it here.
I mean this is some old shit.
What's going on?
The laptop?
Is that the laptop?
Yeah.
Um,
these guys,
if,
if you know,
if you watched this,
I'm,
this is like some real high level Jujitsu still to this day.
This is like,
you could see these guys rolling like with this technique that they're
exhibiting right here.
You can see these guys rolling like this.
And then when the owls,
I mean these are elite,
elite,
elite grapplers and this is back before anybody knew about it.
What year is this Brian?
Say here.
I'll pull it up.
Hold on.
Say previous yard.
No,
it's not.
Yeah.
What's the gross music behind it?
Who did that?
You fuckhead?
Yeah.
19.
Okay.
Well yeah,
that's hard to tell.
I'm trying to find it.
It's a,
it's incredible.
Then when you watch that video,
it's um,
does it say here?
No,
it doesn't say.
I think if I had a gas,
I think it was probably the late eighties,
but I'm not sure.
But a Hixon got them eventually,
eventually he got him.
He could not handle the pace for Hickson's the greatest of all time.
Yeah.
I don't know if fix it tapped him.
I think he did.
Um,
but uh,
Hixon is a,
it says the only person,
oh,
Ron trip is the only person credited.
Oh,
with the a a victory over Hixon Gracie.
But that's just ridiculous because he beat him in judo and all he did was take
him down,
he knee pond them or [inaudible] pond them,
whatever it is.
When someone throws you like a serious throw,
like the,
the match is over.
But Hickson was fine.
Like Hicks wanted to fight to go to the ground so he could submit them.
So when they say you credit a guy with a victory in a match like that,
like,
yeah,
I guess so.
But it's by judo rules.
It's not not what Hickson's doing.
If Hickson and Ron trip were to roll and rancher beat them,
that would be a different thing.
If they were to spar or you know,
have a Jujitsu competition of just an all out grappling competition to
submission.
I got my money on the Brazilian son.
What a great sport.
Yeah,
it's an awesome,
can't wait to get back man.
My back is pretty much a hundred percent now
and the kids I go with the half my age bro,
you know,
and it's just fun.
The goal and they know who you are.
They asked me,
they listened to the podcast,
they want to come watch me perform.
They came to the ice house,
you know,
they really fucking good kids.
And my problem is that I come back on Sundays,
they all go to contest.
I love to go see him and support him.
You know,
like they went to the,
to the Gracies.
Uh,
two of them went to the Nogi part,
but I'm going to be in San Jose for the World Gracie's July 13th.
Oh,
real weekend yet.
I'll stop down by my man,
Dave,
Kevin,
Maria,
another one that my Jujitsu idols,
and then I'd go to the,
to the worlds,
you know,
go watch them and see what it's about.
Lie.
No,
it's really interesting.
I never really watched it.
I'm only went to one match.
You got to come to some of the,
uh,
some of the UFC is,
we haven't seen you in awhile.
I'm
coming.
I'm going to a lunch when you come in.
I'm Alando Orlando,
Sarah in Baltimore and Baltimore.
John Jones.
John over to share.
But I'm,
I'm really excited about Misha Tate and a car MOOC.
That's going to be a fucking barnyard fucking tool.
Gorillas fighting.
It's amazing.
Where listen in a cup and a year,
they won't even need those fucking Ringrose no more.
Unless those bitches could rappel.
Rappel.
We don't need to walking around with some fucking sign that says number three,
go fuck yourself.
We got bitches pulling each other's heads now.
Each in the fucking face.
Why don't they have ring guys?
I think that the girls should have ring guys.
That's what I think,
man.
I mean,
if we're not going to be sexist,
if we're not going to be sexist and you know,
Miesha Tate and Ronda Rousey,
maybe you,
that's what I was thinking.
Come on.
Maybe you would have speedo going like,
come on.
You know how awesome that would be if you were the ring card girl and a speed a
boy in a speedo and some,
some shower sandals.
I think we should take with tap out and say that's my boy.
That's my dog.
Yeah.
You with like a,
an unharnessed like a pair of boxers on harness boxers.
Just loose,
just swinging Dick.
You know like the opening scene of uh,
the um,
Deanna word video where he's flinging his dick up and down.
I remember that part where he's beat boxing and it's in slow motion.
He see his dick.
That'd be you.
That'd he be you as the ring card girl.
I don't know if you watch a play that part of the video.
I don't know if you guys watch a lot of fights afterwards.
I just rewatched the whole Ronda Rousey Meisha take card and that fight,
you know,
you can type quicker with two hands.
That fight was so fucking good.
That fight was so fucking good to Misha Tate and Ronda Rousey was great.
Last one,
and it was so technical and just to see where women have come and where are they
going to go now?
Cause the ones and some gym in San Diego with some gym and Iowa,
the 14 year olds,
they're going to be fucking monsters.
Oh yeah.
Especially now when they see how famous Ronda Rousey's now these 15 year olds,
the training that looked like men and they're like that,
that chicken,
uh,
what was the fat chicken that the baseball movie with Mcdonald will remember?
Gina Carano the other one,
the other one that the father brother and he was telling Jon Lovitz,
you know,
she don't look that good.
And then they brought her out to see John Lovers and John Lewis was like,
like he was scared of him.
He was like,
you can't take her out in the daytime.
Like they have those ugly chicks for the train.
He's somewhere right now.
Oh you're going to be fucking cause see the UFC goes after the hot ones cause
that's what people pay for.
No,
no.
They go after the best fighters.
There's a lot of them that aren't hot at all yet.
The Dick swinging.
If I was,
if I was the one view this is,
you will just find the part where his,
his dick is flopping around.
Don't play the music.
Find it.
Just find the part so we could,
cause I think we'll get in trouble if you play the music.
I don't know if this,
there it is.
That's you.
Joey looks like Einstein.
He looks like Einstein but picture you and some pink Floyd shorts like that.
Carrying the ring card side laying down in Vegas.
Free balling.
Total free ball.
Unharness cock.
I couldn't do it.
They can deal with it.
They would have to add the nut sack.
That's the real wrecking ball.
That nuts that come in behind you.
That's the real fun.
That's the real kettle bell.
Got
that.
Fucking not,
I got this tremendous Doug,
why don't they have ring car boy on the phone and tell him get some pretty
serious.
Is that real quick?
Because the audience is 100% guys almost and then no one wants to see a dude
walking around.
That's the whole life.
The showmanship of boxing and I bet the audience has a,
a an equal proportion it women fighting on the card ratio to women being in the
audience.
It's ratio.
It probably more stronger to women in the audience ratio.
So if you got a card and does nine fights in the card and one of those fights is
a girl fight,
the next one in February of two of those fights are at girl fight to have those
fights are girl fight.
If there's 20% of the audience that are there that are girls,
I say least one ring card boy.
Good.
Yeah.
Chuck Congo with that big show with a song up there shaking that big yoke and
shit.
It's all over like a route,
like a root of an ebony chain or reassign that motherfucker be a ring guy just
bursting through the concrete.
That's what they want to see the size of Congo's copper cause fucking hitting my
Goldberg in the head as he runs by and shit.
It's like one of those routes in an old neighborhood that pushes up the sidewalk
at the time.
I look at Chuck Congo,
I'm like,
damn,
I wonder who he fucked in the ass last night.
He came up to me,
he listened to this talk about his dick on the podcast.
He did and he came up to be laughing.
He's like,
don't here.
It's like shopping towards his leg.
Like,
cause he's the one saves a little bit at the airport.
One days in a load is a good man.
Check on it.
It's a good fire too.
He's fighting.
He's doing well and Beltre just uh,
just one.
One by Tko.
Good fight too against um,
a former,
like a really good fighter.
What the fuck did he fight?
Actually,
I think he's fought twice now.
I think.
So let me pull it out.
But I think I know he fucked Peter Graham proof.
Pretty short.
Fought Peter Graham,
who's a really high level kickboxer and his last,
uh,
last fight.
Mark.
Go goober.
Maybe someone else.
Fuck.
Oh yeah,
I did fight Peter Graham.
Yeah.
Congo versus Kurose Congo.
One by unanimous decision.
That's it.
That's a pretty impressive win because Peter Grams a serious kickboxer,
not like the best MMA fighter like Congo has more MMA experience,
but Peter Grams a motherfucker and kickboxing.
He broke,
bought her hardest job with a cartwheel kick.
You ever see a guy threw a cartwheel kick this ridiculous cartwheel.
Like put your hand on the ground.
We'll kick and he broke,
bought her Harvey's job.
See if he could find that.
Peter Graham Kaos Badr Hari.
It's a crazy kick.
Like really bizarre.
Tick.
Shattered his jaw to knocked him out cold and Him and bought her heart.
He got in a fight,
a press conference,
like fucking full on fist fight at a press conference.
Those Dutch dudes are crazy,
man.
They don't give a fuck.
That's about totally different worlds guy behind your dog.
Elvis.
The best thing that happened,
this guy was that they took them at 70 1977 cause he wouldn't have made out
of the 80s he would have fucked the 80s up.
He had so much money by the time the eighties where the hit,
he would have just been taking women up their spot and below and shooting them.
He don't get him that Memphis Mafia.
They didn't give a fuck.
If you really read about Elvis,
you realize one thing that mother fucker was crazy,
like Sinatra was crazy,
but this mother fucker was crazy.
I read a chapter in the led Zeppelin book with led Zeppelin went to his house
one night and this motherfucker didn't wake up for nobody.
Nobody.
He didn't wake up five or six and they'd better be a cheeseburger and a blow job
waiting from,
that's not part of Badr Hari.
That's Carter Williams.
That's Peter Graham.
This is Carter Williams.
Still wait,
if led Zeppelin got there at lunchtime,
he was out there with a robe on.
He gave bond them has watched this guy was the real deal though.
This guy was the real deal.
Oh Elvis.
He was crazy as it guys watch an old movie couple of weeks.
I'm like,
you don't want,
look at this motherfucker.
It's 2014 this is two Pi.
This was 1950 I would have jumped out a window.
1950 if I would've seen this mother fucker come out and fucking moving.
Jailhouse rock.
God Damn.
Elvis was a fucking soldier.
He was good too,
man.
Fucking good man.
Yeah,
he was fucking good.
Go back.
Especially to the early days and just,
just taking him into account as a musician.
Jailhouse rock.
That's a great,
I love,
that's my jam.
I was a great song.
I love a couple of his fucking jams couple.
He's not.
He has a couple of fucking really good jams and you could feel his personality
and his smile.
It just something about Elvis.
He was just look at them at that point.
He was all fucked up.
He didn't give a fuck.
Fuck you bitch.
Fuck you.
He was wearing sunglasses.
He was so fucking bad.
That's how you know.
Yeah,
yeah.
You're wearing sunglasses in your mugshot and the constantly going and saying,
I'm,
I'm fucking Elvis guy.
Listen man,
let me leave mom.
I can't do it.
I can't do that right in here.
I'm saying things that aren't here.
It's the only things that keep me from the spirit world
plus one for the mind to full the show.
Don't you step on my blue suede shoes?
Who's things that shit?
Shit.
Yeah,
he,
he was a bad motherfucker did he took those chicks to town?
Women didn't.
There it is.
Woo.
That's bought her throwing a wheel kick at him and Peter Graham won up catching
him.
That was a crazy fight.
Hold on.
Where's the
these high level kickboxers might hear this.
Watch this.
Oh Shit.
Play that shit again.
This is,
it's so crazy how he set it up too.
It was like a cartwheel,
like look at his hand drops down when he does it.
He like drops down with his right hand and throws his left leg over the top.
Watch this.
Watch how he does.
Oh No.
Okay.
You know what it was?
He threw a regular wheel kick but he fell so I'm wrong.
He just threw a left leg step.
He stepped in through a left leg,
we'll kick,
but God damn
kick is like getting shot with a sniper rifle.
I wish I could fall among somebody out.
Well that was,
you know,
he fell from the,
the the turn.
The torque of the turn.
That's,
that was incredible kick
by the way.
Edson Barboza the first guy to ever land one of those in the UFC.
He's fighting Donald's.
So Renee,
when that's on Fox in Orlando.
Oh Shit.
Joey D's that caught his path.
That's fucked.
That is,
that's gotten now is uh,
what's his name still at the Maximilian's over him or he left?
Yes.
Oh,
he's still,
well he trains with them.
He's still a part of their team,
but he's,
he did a lot of training in Thailand for his last fight.
Get rid of the keys.
He's Ange.
He's injured right now.
Who,
what Cuban get rid of me or no,
no.
As far as I know,
Amir has been cut.
I haven't heard anything.
I love frame me,
but it's his time.
It's hard to Nigga.
I love him.
I fucking love him.
I'm the one of biggest fans with FLS fight you?
I don't think he's at.
He's not in New Mexico no more for this fight.
He wasn't,
he wasn't,
he doesn't like training away from home.
You know it's like to keep up with these new animals,
you have to keep yourself up at a different fucking pace.
It's like me saying to you,
you know,
want for my CD wide paper.
I'm not going to go on the road.
I'm just gonna.
I'm just gonna do sets it.
The flap is going to go.
Okay Joey.
Hey Joey.
Okay,
Joey,
you're not going to go on a fucking wrong.
You're not going to go on the road and try your material.
You don't go to flappers and do 10 minutes every fucking night.
That's what you're telling me.
Okay,
Joey.
Okay.
That's what it's like to me when you do a training camp,
I think you should go and you know,
sank in for six weeks.
It's like when I was a kid you had basketball and football camps and people
couldn't figure out like every time I put doctor she,
Joe Rogan,
he went to Willis Reed basketball camp.
That motherfucker came back better than ever.
No,
because for five days you were around pros and then told you little things like,
Hey,
don't put the ball past your waist.
They just corrected you.
I'm like,
I went to Joe Namath football camp.
One of the best experiences I've had,
I came back faster.
Yeah,
I came back faster because they taught you how to run from seven 30 to eight
every morning.
They taught you how to run something.
Nobody ever did.
Sometimes it's just being around,
seeing the guy hits a ball grade senior guy who runs fast makes you want to run
faster.
It makes you really want to dig in.
Seeing guys that are really good at a sport and it takes that emotion of being
home,
my wife and this and this.
You know what?
I'll hang till nine what's the rush?
Well,
married,
I got to leave Jujitsu and run home.
Then when you're not,
you can stay at the gym till 10 o'clock at night because after the seven o'clock
train in this talk,
because when we fight him,
watch with a right hook,
right for the left field.
So that's why I always start training away.
He's very smart.
Fighters don't like it.
It's just hard on their families.
Sure.
That's,
that's where guys bring us,
we leave every other fucking week,
six weeks,
six,
six weeks away.
It's a long time.
That's not two days blown.
Disappear for fuck.
No I can't.
I gotta come back in three days.
I lose my fucking mind.
I agree with you though.
I think the only way to do it and compete at the highest levels,
you got to go somewhere or be lucky that you live in a town,
like if he live in New Mexico,
if you live in La,
you know,
and you're around the corner.
Yeah.
Duke or something,
you know,
at rain or you're at a king's MMA or something like that.
But still,
I think you got to move around.
Even with me.
They tell me,
listen,
Joey,
you know,
you come here to g g macros or White v Mac where I go for Jujitsu.
Which one?
White belts school.
They only been open for two years.
They got a couple of blue bumps they put on.
So a lot of John Joc people come down.
I don't have the ball.
You're just in it for a good exercise,
but I'm in it to learn something.
You know,
I got a daughter,
somebody attached and I looked to take them down north,
south him and get the fuck out of it.
You know,
I'm going to kill Eddie Bravo.
Call me.
He's like,
dog.
Well you need to do is learn to Nordstrom.
Don't fuck with anything else.
Just north,
south,
north,
south kick.
Yeah,
but no,
he to tell me.
And then Salamis got a nasty north south.
That's what I heard.
I heard the Russians got the nasty side of all of them.
Oh,
he,
he's got to call me to talk to talk to Rashonda by learning
whatever sign is a really good north south.
Just go with it.
So I ended up at van eyes,
10th planet and fucking the guy did it to me,
bro.
My eyebrow was fucked up for three hours.
That's how good the north south choke from him.
He was like,
God,
he just taught me how to do it correctly.
It's harder with the Geek.
He told me that it's better Gnocchi.
I Dunno know,
I just,
I just need to,
it's harder to get your arm in the right position
to meet.
My eyebrow was blinking for like three hours on the one on one.
They kept fucking Blinken.
That's how hard he tapped my fucking face dog.
Yeah,
that can be a choke or it could be a neck crank depending on how you get it.
Uh,
Jamie Varner tried for it in his last fight was the first round right there.
He tried it and you begin to see that he was,
there was space between his chest in the ground and when you watch her son do it
or assign,
gets his lap on the side of your head and he gets this forum under your neck and
he's pinned down to the ground and he is squeezing the holy fucking Jesus out of
your neck.
It's technique.
It's all about getting in the perfect position.
It's like the difference between trying to finish off a triangle when it's over
your toes and taking the time to adjust when it's over the ankle and you get
that real solid fucking death triangle that no one gets out and then you pull
the head.
You know the guys who leave it on the toes.
Either they're afraid that in the transition and adjustment that they're going
to lose the position or they just don't have a good triangle,
but whatever the reason is,
it's this little details,
little details,
not over the toes,
but over here.
Bam.
That's one of the things that Eddie is so good at.
Eddie Bravo,
in my opinion,
is one of the best instructors in the world,
and I don't just say this because he's one of my favorite human beings and my
best friend,
he's a brilliant instructor,
like the way he breaks down positions and tells you about all the possible fit
pitfalls.
He's one of the best in the world.
I mean I think there's a series of best in worlds.
There might not be one best in the world.
John John Machado is clearly also one of the best in the world.
Drop Lino.
Clearly one of the best.
Nora oiler Gracie,
one of the best of the world hoists he,
Ron Henner.
There's a whole series of them,
but any Bravo's right up there with them.
That motherfucker breaks down positions very technically and gives you this like
really strong path and then gives you adjustments to deal with pitfalls in each
path.
Like what happens when you lose that position,
but then you go back to this and then you stop from here,
make sure he doesn't go here.
It's all like so technical and so broken down as like a,
as a science,
like a mathematical science.
Almost.
One thing I did notice about John Jocks,
guys,
they kill us.
Oh yeah,
no doubt.
John Joc trains his people and they,
the people that trained me from John John,
I could see how they stress like Joey fucking use your weight guy but that
fucking form and his fate like Dell,
like Joe,
you're being nice to this guy.
Why are you being so nice to this guy?
Put Your fucking phone.
I can't hurt nobody.
I don't have it in me.
Put Your fucking foreman did that.
That they know like this one brown book took me,
this guy was dirty from,
from,
he was a Spanish gift from John John's and this kid was like,
dog,
I'm just north side.
I want you to twist this motherfucking rip that fucking on.
That's all you're doing.
Fuck that.
North South Pussy Shit.
This guy was like,
rip it.
That's what you got.
Take that fucking Geek.
Pulled them in,
grabbed that wrist and pull that fucking arm back.
Sounds like a nightmare to row with guy to this guy was on me.
I mean he fucked me up,
but he was running.
He goes,
you've got this weight,
you're wasting it.
Why are you wasting this fucking wife?
I don't think it's creative.
For me it's like for me it's like improvising.
I could go in there and improvise and anytime I want and it's a 50 50 shot.
I don't like using my weight.
I rather,
I love attacking from the bottom too.
Fucking fat.
Not a shape,
but that's my,
you can work on that though.
If you just watch it,
I could do it.
I love it.
I fucking lost 80 pounds.
I love it Bro.
I love and I've lost 18 since at this stop.
That's beautiful bro.
I love,
you know,
I could do a,
like the other night some Japanese girl fucked me up.
I was just working on my garden.
I was just,
I just wanted to hold her in my guard.
But the guy who really to like the John Jack Black Belt who teach me.
It's funny,
somebody said to me,
you know that guy and then John junk have moves like from 1960s but they're,
your type of mood was like the first movie taught me was when they tried to
butterfly and I put my knee in his ass and pick his legs up and I was doing that
all the time and killing people and just weighing on him and shit.
And he's like,
that's an old school,
old school trick trick.
All those little things.
That's what he has.
And I could see where Eddie came in and evolve a lot of those moves now.
Now I understand the beauty of Eddie Bravo when you guys are just talk to me in
a car.
I didn't know what the fuck you were saying.
I mean there's only one way to unborn motherfucker.
What are you guys talking about though?
He made it better.
I understand now the transition into the arm bar and all that shit.
I get it now.
Well,
John Jock,
you know,
one of the beautiful things about John Jack is that he encourages people to work
on new moves and try new things and he's very open.
He rose with everybody and you know,
he's one of the best in the world.
I mean John Jackets,
he mean he's a a red belt on a Hixon Gracie.
I mean Hixon gave miss red belt.
That's like master status.
I mean,
and I would,
I would say there's,
you know,
maybe five people on the planet that have the type of Jujitsu knowledge that
John Jack has means a real old school master.
But he's also very open minded
and he likes when people do different things.
And one of the reason is because he had to improvise a lot and change things a
lot himself because he was born on one of his hands,
his left hand,
he only has a thumb,
so he can't grab things like you were,
I can.
So he developed a bunch of techniques based on under hooks and over hooks
instead of what a lot of the key players are doing,
which was grabbing collars and grabbing sleeves because he couldn't control you
with two hands grasping things like this.
So he developed a more Greco Roman based style.
So when they went to Abu Dhabi,
when Abu Dhabi started the first submission championships,
Jacques was real running through motherfuckers and one of the reasons being is
John Jack didn't need a key,
like the [inaudible] didn't help him at all.
He didn't hit me,
he knew how to use it,
but John Jack was just as good without the g as with the gay.
And that was rare for a Brazilian jujitsu black belt because so many guys had
concentrated on training by grabbing a hold of the Geeky and grabbing hold the
pants and grabbing a hold of collars in a one hand,
it makes you more technical because you have to be really careful about your
defense when you're in a gay cause.
If a guy traps your arm and you're going to be,
you can't just pull out of it when you can,
like you can,
if you're all sweaty.
So it requires like a more tactical defensive,
uh,
attack or a defensive,
maneuvering.
And you gotta,
you gotta be real careful of getting yourself in a bad position to try to ape
out of them cause you might not ever be able to.
But John Jock was all over hooks and under hook,
so he didn't lose a step and he went into Aba dominant.
It's just like smashing guys.
The guys like soccer.
I like really high level,
like w MMA competitors and John [inaudible] is dominating them on the ground,
just dominating them,
taking their back,
choke in the fucking shit out of him,
sliding his one hand that,
you know,
he uh,
he,
uh,
he doesn't have a hand on it.
It fits into places where the hands get trapped.
So he figured out that he could get his,
like his,
his hand that doesn't have fingers.
It's,
there's not as much mass.
So he put like a point,
he slides it under your Chin and chokes the fucking shit out of you with it.
Like John Jack is actually almost more dangerous because he only had one hand
that just shows you like what human ingenuity can,
can come up with when you're in a situation where like give you seen as Nick
Newell Kid,
you know who he is,
he's an MMA fighter who has one arm and he's fucking people up.
He's fighting for the world series of fighting and a,
I'm pretty sure he's fighting for the title in his next fight and this fucking
kid is a beast.
He's got one arm,
he's got a right arm,
his left arm,
he was born with a and some sort of a birth defect,
whereas arms,
the only goes down to his elbow,
but he's still strangling motherfuckers,
taking guys down,
Ghia,
team them.
He's got this nasty guillotine that he does with like the one arm that's enough
and then the other full arm and it's like he gets you in that and it's your,
it's your ass,
it's death,
it's death.
Pull up Nick Newell,
Guillotine Choke.
It's a really impressive,
I love seeing shit like that,
man.
I love seeing someone who overcomes something that,
you know,
they just got a shit hand that the,
the World Delta,
they got,
they,
the world delta.
They don't even think about it.
They're like,
fuck it.
I'm going to move on.
Well,
it makes him so determined,
you know,
it just shows you how much,
how much about succeeding at something is in the mind.
And how much is the mind finding the correct path.
Finding a way to overcome the mind is everything.
It's not just the body.
Because if a guy like this can be this successful,
I mean,
granted he's fighting in an organization where he's facing a level competition,
uh,
a step below the UFC.
I'm still,
as a person who's been analyzing fights most of my life,
I'm still impressed with them.
I'm very impressed with him.
He's dangerous.
This kids fucking real.
Like I'm looking at that gaiety and my dad is a death guillotine.
You get caught in that fucking thing.
He's going to squeeze the blood out of your brain.
You Ain't getting out.
It doesn't matter if he's got one arm.
I'm watching that.
He's doing this nickname,
Neal Newell,
Newell,
n.
E.
W.
L.
I'm watching how he's doing this and I'm like,
this kid is an animal.
He's scary.
I had a teacher in high school,
Mr Pennock,
Coochie lost when I'm in Vietnam to his elbow.
What a great name.
He would fucking hit you with that stub during class.
If you disrespect him,
he would clock you with that fucking stub and you don't know what the fuck to
do.
You know what I'm saying?
Wow.
That's hilarious.
See if you can find,
just find what it is,
a videos cause he always wins by guillotine.
Just load it up and let me know when it's ready.
Okay.
Um,
so did you hear what happened with the UFC this weekend?
Rashad Evans,
yes.
Gets injured.
They're going to qualify it off with Columbia,
but they had a replacement online.
Pat Comments,
that comment,
who I've known for a while,
Ryan has been,
Ryan's had this kid for awhile and he has a hardest time getting them fights.
Nobody wants to fight this kid.
He's a fucking beast,
man.
He's a beast.
I mean,
what a tall order.
Ryan Parsons,
he's vying Parsons Guy,
the guy who got hit with a golf ball.
Same Guy.
I Love Ryan Parsons.
I can't even think about that.
Then we get no fucking play golf.
Normal.
Six months,
six months.
Fucked up.
Yeah.
Well this kid,
pat is something,
man.
He's been talking about this kid for a long time.
I mean,
huge,
huge order for this kid.
I mean,
what a difficult task you're taking out more the best fucking wrestlers in the
world.
And Daniel Cormier,
as far as MMA,
one of the best wrestlers to ever fight in MMA.
What is this gala team?
It's in ethic yet?
No,
no.
Nick Newell.
Newell Gear Team.
This is him in a,
a a grappling match.
Oh,
that's not him,
man.
It's got two arms of Jesus Christ.
Nick Newell,
n e w e l.
L.
Nothing.
Mm.
A gay teen.
Don't make me find it.
You fuck.
Might be it.
Um,
so this guy,
um,
who,
uh,
who we both know,
I know pat pretty well and uh,
I know that,
um,
Ryan has been trying to get this kid a fight for a long time,
but nobody wants to find them.
It's really hard to get in fights and smaller shows because they find out about
his wrestling credentials
and they're like,
oh,
Jesus,
two time,
all American u s national and a undefeated fighter,
Pat Commons now face the undefeated Daniel Cormier.
It's fucking crazy,
crazy tasks though to take that ad.
A,
um,
uh,
you know,
it's such a short notice,
but he used an undefeated collegiate wrestler.
There's going to be a good fight if you don't,
you,
you know,
undefeated fighter actually stand for me as improved every time he bro,
everybody believable.
It makes leaps and fucking bounds that guy and the sweetest fucking guy in the
world.
Oh yeah.
The sweetest creole motherfucker.
You can meet the sweetest guy in the world.
Yeah.
He came to one of the shows when I did the big one in San Jose and we spoke for
a little while on the back and it was just,
it really was really nice talking to him.
What a great guy.
And he's friends with what,
you know he's rendered Stevie Marcos,
right.
And all those guys.
So which King Mall a King?
Mo lost two.
Um,
the hardcore kid.
What's his name?
Emmanuel Newton.
He lost a manual Newton.
So he's got one,
he's got one arm.
It's choking.
Oh my God.
What about the guy who was the black guy with the dreads from Africa?
So could you show,
where is he?
So could you lost two Musashi?
Who is fighting Machida this weekend?
You also lost the Glover to share [inaudible] last step.
Machida,
the first fight.
And that was cheated on her,
but she is a,
that was the one that you,
I was like,
oh yeah,
it's a big black guys and a fuck him up.
I was at the fight.
You took me.
Yeah.
So could you as,
I think the,
the last loss was Musafa.
He's still fighting out of Henderson's camp because he was out there for a
while.
I don't know.
I don't know about that.
I know he was,
but uh,
he was a guy that was an unbelievable athlete.
Incredible judo.
What?
Fuck physical strength.
That guy too.
So could you just for whatever reason,
injuries his head,
who knows what it was,
just never quite put it together.
Not In the UFC.
Maybe he'll come back and we got Robbie Lawler put it together.
Well that's the thing about circuit.
He's still a young guy.
A lot of people don't know how long this stuff,
not even 30 yet.
He'll be back in the U S at least.
I don't think he has.
At least he wasn't back then.
I mean maybe he's 30 now,
but when he first began his career,
I'm pretty sure he's pretty young guy to imagine when it's,
it's really,
uh,
a great thing to see when you're struggling for a long time and all of a sudden
everything comes together.
At one time we were talking about Mark Maryland.
I came in here how I did this TV show on it podcast.
And that,
you know,
I don't know what went on or whatever.
I never had no problems with the guy.
And he reached out to me.
I did the podcast.
It was really good.
You guys had a thing a long time ago.
He used some something stupid.
Well,
you know,
he was also,
for the longest time,
mark was just not that happy because he wasn't doing that well and he knew he
was a good comic,
but he just,
for whatever reason that things weren't clicking for him,
he wasn't getting the success that he wanted.
So he was more irritable,
you know?
So a lot of the conflict was kind of created during that period of disturbed the
of turmoil,
turmoil in his life.
But now he's pretty chill.
I've known Mark A.
Long time.
And one thing about Mark Marin's,
he's always been a hard worker.
Yeah.
After I met mark,
you went to New York and put a up,
he went to Israel when he put that plan together.
That was a great reason why Michelle wrote a book too.
Yeah,
that was a great thing.
You know,
Mark's never stopped from,
no,
that's the marker.
Real comics is that we don't stop you just because you don't see me.
It's like I tell people all the time,
look,
Joe Diaz is funny and we have a great time on the podcast,
but you're missing out on life if you don't get to go see David,
tell this shit.
You're really missing out on life if you don't see some of these old timers that
are in selling tickets just because they're not someone to tickets to go see
him.
Go see Jim Breuer.
He's squeaky clean and a blow your fucking shit.
I told,
I heard bro,
you know the squeaky clean and murdering,
so I heard about brewer.
I heard he's murdering a Gi bill.
Bird told me that Jim brewers bit about his dad shitting his pants is possibly
the funniest thing he's ever seen.
His life.
Britain brewers,
a monster who was a monster for years,
for years.
You told me you had a hard time once.
Found them to idea.
I bombed following him.
It wasn't a hard time.
I ate did.
He was one of the only time guys in Miami.
I used to follow them.
You know Miami.
I wrote my own ticket.
I the two lines of coke and went up there.
I'd take your fucking head off dude.
I watery.
I worked with you in Miami.
That motherfucker went up to and was like,
watch this bitch and just shut everybody the fuck.
Damn.
This is when he was getting high.
Now he's clean and sober.
He's a,
he's just like that if not better.
Better Bro.
It's 20 years.
It's 15 years and it all comes together.
Just like Robbie loyal.
Yeah.
It all comes together.
After a while you,
you shut this whole down,
this whole catch better.
This thing gets better.
This isn't a weakness no more.
Do you know what we found out about Robbie Lawler found?
It's about from war machine yesterday and Mike Sessman 11 he listened to the
podcast and then he got ahold of me on Twitter and let me know what's true.
Robbie Lawler doesn't spar.
He wrestles and he does all of his striking work,
kicking pads and hitting the mitts and hitting the back.
So he goes into these fights with no damage.
He goes in his fights with a rock solid chin.
He goes into these fights with no,
no punishment on his body.
I mean,
a little punishment,
I'm sure from wrestling,
but he,
and they ask him why?
He's like,
why should I do that?
I already know how to fight.
I mean,
if he wasn't knocking people the fuck out,
I would,
I would question it.
But we played his fight yesterday with Melvin Manhoef when he knocked out Melvin
Manhoef,
you know,
and look at,
he just did the Rory Mcdonald.
He,
he had Lord Roy McDonald had deep shit.
Shit.
He's a bad motherfucker.
Him and Hendrix is a co crazy fight.
That's a crazy damn.
I can't wait to see that fight.
That could fucking top notch.
Fine.
But imagine that he says he doesn't spar.
He's very smart.
He put it together.
That's incredible.
He said,
you know what,
I got an idea.
I'm not going to go in there with a black guy on my hair and I'm going to go in
there and fucking fresh and kill somebody and then it might work for him.
It might not work for somebody else,
Bro.
You know why I think it probably works for him cause he's so calm.
He's so calm.
He's been doing it so long.
Like he's so cute and you know,
they offered him to fight for the title.
He said cool.
That's pretty sad.
He's got,
he's got like this weird stoic demeanor.
So I think that he doesn't get to rattled and worry about the timing like some
people would do.
He just goes after it.
He's,
he's know guys like him.
The guy from New Orleans took the crazy kid from New Orleans.
The brother Tim Crater?
No,
the white.
The Black Alan Belcher from New Orleans.
Melvin Gallard.
Alvin Gla.
Yeah.
We've had over 40 fights record.
That's what you heard about.
What about the other 20th they didn't.
Confidence is right there.
You see somebody like John Jack on the bottom,
me and he was sweating.
I'm on the bottom.
I'm dying.
I'm about to shit my pants got,
that's experience.
You know when I go on the stage now and I say to jokes and they're going to
matter,
I don't give a fuck.
I'm gonna get myself on this motherfucking hole.
That's experience.
You know you do.
Sometimes I go on stage and I do things that I know I couldn't do six years ago.
Right.
I know I couldn't do shotgun.
Robbie Lawler is really doing that and not sparring and camp than he.
He has a longer life in fighting than a lot of people because the only punches,
he's taken their t's taking them in fights,
but he's still going into the fight with a lot of Mitt work.
He's still going into the fight,
hitting the bag.
It's still going to fight using rubber bands and weights.
He still is visualizing.
He's still the guys holding the pads.
He's ripping to the body.
When the guys are wearing body shields,
he's still hitting things real interesting,
man.
Real interesting because if,
if that turns out to be like an effective strategy,
boy that's going to recap.
I mean,
I don't know if it worked for everybody.
It might not work for everybody,
but for him,
if he can find other guys that follows that boy,
your career would last longer.
I may ask you a question.
Let's say you take your comedy.
Let's say you're doing this special
and your goal is to write every day,
two hours,
one hour in the morning,
one in the afternoon,
and then you'd do a set at night.
Let's pretend you don't go out that night and do a set for one month.
You just stay in and write that extra hour.
Do you think it's going to affect your performance now that that's on me?
That's what he's doing.
The same thing a different way.
If I was a comic getting ready for something
I just said to you joining and a waste my time going up and says the difference
is he's not taking damage.
When you're sitting at home and you're,
you're not going to comedy clubs,
there's no benefit.
What he's getting is a very big physical benefit.
Meaning everybody goes into fights,
busted up,
everybody goes into fights with short ribs.
Everybody goes into fights with a headache.
They going to fight with a sore nose.
They might have loose teeth,
they might have fucking hurt hands.
He's not that.
That's an advantage.
That's a physical,
tangible advantage.
My point is,
look at Rodney Rodney quick comedy all those years when he came back at four
notebooks worth of jokes,
right?
For years,
they were kept putting them on TV and every time you show it,
Rodney at six,
no minutes,
people couldn't figure it out.
What's a biography?
It was that this mother fucker had eight notebooks all those years that he
wasn't right going on stage.
You kept writing,
kept writing and every time he did a new six minutes,
they're like,
what the fuck?
He's got 10 hours.
God,
you're slipping with this guy.
So I think,
you know if this nights that I have a thing though,
if I work during the week,
you know,
Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday,
I take a plane at five in the morning.
I won't go out during the week but I'll take that time and write a little bit at
night just so I have a different avenue to go in there with.
If I'm not going to waste my time at night cause I'm out all fucking week.
I'm going to go out two nights,
three nights during the week and then for talk to people know I'm 50 fucking one
next week and you'll know that.
I think there's a big balance which we were writing and performing.
I think you got to do both.
I think the difference between us and a fighter is that a fighter is making a
strategy.
Look.
Obviously his performances having suffered at all,
he looks amazing.
I mean that fight with Roy McDonald was a fucking fantastic performance fight.
Josh Koscheck you destroyed your scarf second the first round,
so he's not suffering by this strategy and it works for him.
Every athlete's different.
Plus it gives them more of a reason to get the fuck out.
Then this motherfucker out.
Yeah,
wait,
take it out there.
I haven't got stage four,
but see with standup,
I think if you don't go off stage for a month,
it's different.
It fucks you up a little bit.
It's definitely a,
it's definitely up.
That's why going Thursdays,
Thursdays is my throwaway not,
I got a sheet of paper with everything I wrote during the week.
I got 120 hundred and 50 people and I just go,
I close with my regular routine,
but through all that shit out to see what I could grab it.
I'm just grasping for straws on Thursday night because I don't go out during the
week,
Friday and Saturday,
my Monday nights,
Thursday got a buck 20 I'll give him a good show,
but I'll throw out some new shit in that just to catch up for the week to see
what I wrote.
Maybe it's not funny and if you don't do that,
those jokes don't get told and they don't get made.
I mean,
think about how many jokes that you have where you started out and it was kind
of a premise and I've seen you like have bits that started out and they just
stay,
just weren't clicking.
There was something missing.
And then I see you like four weeks later and boom it slam and you figured out
the right path.
You figured out how to shorten it up,
you figured out how to get to the funny part quicker,
boom.
And then it's,
it's killing.
Got To start somewhere.
You know,
it's funny,
uh,
again,
when I was in a sense doing the thing with Mark Merrill,
he looked at me and he goes,
oh it is it to get workout space anymore.
He goes,
it sucks cause everybody wants you to perform.
Yeah.
As long as the days of going through the store on a Tuesday and just ripping a
notebook and going,
because people are showing up to really see you,
you know,
and did you see what he's doing?
And he got a theater cause he said he was drunk.
I go on the road in two weeks,
I have zero material.
Zero.
You know how it is your TV show for fucking six months and he goes,
he gets out twice a week.
So I go,
what are you going to do?
So he tweeted that he got a fever,
some little theater on Santa Monica Boulevard,
right.
He's going to do shows for two weeks.
All the money benefits to feed it.
Wow.
That's going to take the money.
And he's,
you know,
and that's uh,
guys like us need somewhere to go and just talk and he's going to do it every
night of the week.
I Dunno how many nights really?
I don't know what nights.
And it's a great idea.
That's a great idea.
Yeah.
It's perfect for him too because he know her only get his people that know what
he's doing and they won't be in this unfair expectation or this weirdness and
he'll be able to form the bits that way.
When I was talking to Tim Allen,
he was like,
I'm going to Vegas and fucking Jamie Masada keeps putting my name on the fucking
bored.
I don't want nobody to come see me.
It got Tim Allen's,
let me tell you how crazy it got for tomorrow.
I got to the point where he was showing up on Tuesdays just to do the three
minutes because he know Jamie wouldn't put his name on the fucking board.
Ah,
that's hilarious.
Hilarious.
He just wanted to try just talk.
Yeah,
just talk.
But when you go up to come in and say that people clap and they expect you to be
funny and you just can't try your shit out.
So I saw him go on stage after a long time off one night in the main room at the
comedy store.
It was weird.
You could tell he's just like,
he just hadn't done it in a long time.
You'd see him like,
I mean you watched the old specials before is before his show,
before home improvement and you would see him like do his comedy is like so much
confidence and speed to it and so much energy to them and it's just so good.
Sharp,
sharp.
But then you saw him after the show and it was just like,
you know,
just trying to step on the stage and oh,
how would I stand right here?
And you know,
just weird.
You could see he just,
it wasn't a part of him anymore.
He'd let it go away.
I wonder if they,
I had heard the rumor that they wanted him to not do comedy while he was doing
home improvement cause is uh,
the show was such a family show and his act was so,
you know,
kind of funky.
You never know.
I mean it wasn't even that,
that radical and act,
it was just pretty,
pretty mainstream.
Normal Act.
I mean you never know what they tell you.
You know,
I just love doing it.
I love getting them.
Like last night I went on stage and had a great fucking time.
You know,
just the Wednesday night [inaudible] gives a fuck.
I don't like going to Hollywood,
no mall.
No,
I like the Improv.
I like the end,
but I still like doing the Improv.
I did it a couple of weeks ago.
It was great.
I enjoy this.
I called for spots at the laugh factory for next week,
but long beach brother got me that.
Got Spot.
All right,
I'll go with you.
Let's do it.
I got like Long Beach.
Let's do a week night.
Like maybe next week or so.
I really like it.
I really like it down.
You do Thursdays every Thursday.
That's when they gave me Thursdays.
It closes at 10 so we're out of there.
Bitch.
What time do you leave to get down there?
Two in the afternoon.
No,
no,
no.
Cause I think the five for the second time.
Cause that's it.
It shows the eight o'clock guys.
Okay.
So what time do you leave?
I leave my house at eight 30 the show's at eight and you leave at eight 30.
Oh your honor.
Your honor.
Okay.
30 minutes.
It's real fucking,
I don't look,
I don't touch the one thing.
I go to five to the one to the one.
Uh,
whatever the fuck I just said to find four or fives.
The motherfucker you want to ignore this weekend guys,
ignore that motherfucker.
Pretend it's not real.
The fives bad too though.
Especially near near the Disneyland.
Oh,
by,
by farm boots.
Whatever.
That is.
Not Boone's farm.
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
The,
you didn't know about gems.
Zillow this weekend.
What are we doing?
Four or five north this weekend?
Dog.
Tomorrow.
One day they're going to,
uh,
is that bridge Hov Lane?
10 miles of the four.
Oh five.
What a good idea.
It's not like it's Valentine's Day or anything.
Nobody felt traveling.
What about the motherfuckers in New York?
They ain't gonna be no Valentine's Day and New York drag.
Yeah.
How much?
How much do I think here?
We've got eight today.
My friends got eight and they got another six tonight and they're going to get
three more on Saturday.
But the city shut down completely.
Like the fucking Jersey road.
Just shut down.
It's fucking,
it's amazing what's going on back there.
I love it.
Wow.
Yeah,
they're getting a lot of snow.
You remember when,
uh,
Bloomberg was mayor and they forgot to pay for snowplows.
They didn't a budget in for plowing snow and people were like trapped in their
fucking houses
and they were all making these videos of people slamming into cars,
like trying to get out of their spots and drive down unplowed roads,
tractor clearing snow kills pregnant New York home and Jesus Christ.
Fucking,
God
dammit.
Where are you going for Valentine's Day?
Joy?
My wife's side of the town.
You guys talk?
I got a beat.
My wife's in Nashville with the baby.
The father is sick,
so she went back there until Tuesday to spend time with the father and the baby
in the whole fucking deal.
So you gonna take me out I think.
Yeah.
What do you want to go?
Kind of spot tomorrow night and Saturday.
So it's all worked working there every time for me.
You don't have no shows this weekend?
No.
I took it off because I was like,
I don't know,
will you?
Will you take?
Who's your Valentine?
No one.
What about that cute chick?
He used to see what?
You got so many bitches.
You know what I'm saying?
I don't even know no more.
Which one?
I don't know.
You got a bunch of bitches.
I don't have anyone.
Don't be bullshit because soccer.
MMM.
I don't.
Where are you playing this weekend?
A flat,
uh,
Jon Lovitz Saturday and Sunday.
Friday night.
I uh,
am playing La Jolla comedy store.
MMM.
February 28th or March 1st we're having four or five shows.
Me,
Tony Hinchcliffe,
Sarah Wine Shank,
bunch of other people.
Have you done that?
Do you miss doing like the La La Jolla comedy store?
Any that,
any of that now?
Did you ever do it much heart?
That was my spot.
The lowboy comedy club.
Do you like staying at the condo is a big rats there.
I would come right home every Saturday,
every Friday and Saturday.
I don't spend the night in San Diego.
I come right home.
I leave at 1145.
I'm home by like fucking one 30 and San Diego.
Yeah.
I don't like spending the night.
Did you ever stay at the condo down there?
Definitely the places that dump,
Oh my God,
it was disgusting.
Their comedy store,
Condo Woo.
Then we still,
they move to an apartment like I guess there are renovating the Condo and I
moved to an apartment.
Apartment was nice.
Then the second time we got me a hotel room.
Yeah,
we had enough.
I had that fear factor money burning a hole in my pocket.
This hotel,
it's like right next door.
That's really nice.
Where I was like,
let's say like gentlemen,
we'll still like gentlemen and again,
I see a towel.
How about that fucking Mexican joint across the street from the hotel that had
that unsane chicken burritos.
Insane.
I'm still there.
I forgot the one around the devotees.
Yeah.
They were so big that you could start eating them and start walking to Mexico
and you would get to Mexico.
Right when the Burrito was done.
These guys are telling me about all these fucking food spots on sunset to the
delicious.
I just don't go to Hollywood at night.
They say there's a Mexican place across the street from the laugh factory.
Willie Taco place,
peachy peach body are right across the street where Virgin Mega store,
you should be there now.
Virgin has gone right Virgin Mega store or was it tower records?
Was it tower records,
records,
something.
Was there tower in Hollywood,
one of those,
virgin or tower.
They say that the fucking place where you always talk about it now.
What's the place
you always talk about that?
You say you go late night,
they're open till three or four fat sounds and what did they have there?
It's just huge.
It's like the sandwiches.
It's,
it's owned by the guy from entourage.
Turtle from entourage and it's just like these huge sandwiches that they have
like fries,
like they have cheese fries instead of fries on the sandwich.
They have cheese fries on a sandwich and they have Google.
Yeah.
If you walk,
you look at and you're like,
this is the worst thing ever to eat.
Crazy delicious.
It's always packed.
Smart move,
man.
Take that entourage money.
Invest it.
She was not entourage now,
but Ronda Rousey's.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
There's a sheet in the movie or the TV show.
Movie movie.
There's
an entourage movie.
She's going to start in the movie and she's got another movie that they're
making totally for her with her as a star
blowing up like the world trade.
Oh,
because they say she might retire after this fight.
The shoot the shit retire,
retiring.
Shit.
She likes beating the fuck out of checks.
She absolutely likes it.
She enjoys it.
She's really good at it and she's really good at doing it.
Even with all the pressure of that,
like Misha Tate fight all the media pressure.
Dude,
her judo is the best judo in MMA right now.
Those fucking throws that she hit me Hsa with me.
She got high on her and just launched.
You know what I mean?
If you,
if you're shooting on Rhonda,
you have to be blower hips.
You gotta be,
you can't be up high,
have you shoot on her and you think you got to rest under her armpits like you
can with other girls.
She's gonna get an under hook and get her leg across your leg and you are going
fly in.
She throws bitches.
But the chicks he's fighting this weekend is Sara Mcmann.
Sarah McMahon is an Olympic silver medalist.
He's built like Gleason t bow.
You ever see her?
Sarah McMahon is fucking huge.
Dude.
She looks like me in a dress.
I'm not joking for a girl like she has arms,
like a guy that's going to be a good fight.
Yeah,
she's really powerful man.
And she's a really good wrestler.
Her technique is excellent,
you know,
and she's a silver medalist in the Olympics and Rhonda is a bronze medalist in
judo.
This is the first time in the history of the UFC.
Two medalists are going at it.
Two Olympic medalists and they both happen to be women.
I mean,
it's fucking crazy.
It's a huge significant fight.
Like for women's MMA.
I mean you talk about like legitimizing it,
it's silver medalist in the Olympics and a bronze medalist in judo.
One in a,
one in wrestling and one in judo.
That's crazy people.
It's never happened.
It sounds a lot of seats.
People love to see those lists.
Will,
should have the last fight,
man,
that was,
you know,
it was a shame what happened,
man,
to sign that card.
But that fucking fight sheet that would mean I watched it with Red Bay.
We were on our feet,
your house,
we were fucking blown crazy fight.
The only other time to Olympians or thought was two gold medalists Rulon Gardner
and Yoshida fought in pride.
Um,
and Rulon Gardner.
That was before he was on biggest loser or one of those shows where he tried to,
he got like way high like in the four hundreds,
and he was like really unhealthy and he had to lose weight to get down there.
Sarah McMahon,
she's,
she's tough dude.
The chicks tough.
Let me Go pee real quick.
You Go pee fella.
There's a picture of her,
uh,
in the,
the Promo clip where she stands there like in that picture,
arms aren't pumped up with blood,
but she stands up after a fight and she raised her arms and be like,
cheese us.
Fuck.
They're huge.
She's strong as shit.
She's probably going to be the strongest woman that Ron has fought in her career
and probably also going to have the best grappling technique at anybody run has
ever fog because her takedown defense is just impeccable.
Plus her,
her grappling knowledge,
like she won't do the same sort of things that may be other opponents have done
that has allowed Rhonda toss them.
She's going to be more on point with their takedown defense.
So to become much more interesting,
but Ronda Rousey,
in my opinion,
she has the bay,
not just the best judo in MMA,
but the best arm bars.
Her arm bar technique is flawless and she hits it from everywhere and there's no
space.
Like when she slaps an arm bar on someone,
everything is tight,
all,
every,
everything is in perfect position and she's so used to people moving when you
buck one way,
she's ready for you to do that.
So she's already countering it and then she just rolls with you and it gets it
tighter if you buck the other way.
She's got that planned out too.
Like she's so good at writing.
You like a bull when you start bucking and twist and to try and get out of that
arm bar,
she is,
follows you and she does it so often because she's so good at this one
technique.
She just hits that arm bar over and over and over and over again.
Her arm bars a thing of beauty that you can't,
you couldn't pick a better fighter to watch.
If you wanted to learn how to do an arm bar,
then Ronda Rousey couldn't pick a better fighter.
Her fucking technique's flawless.
I mean,
I,
I learned something new every time I watch your head and arm bar,
that's not bullshit.
I learned new setups.
I learned new transitions and learn new recoveries,
how she recovers from losing a position and she doesn't even hold the legs a lot
of the times.
Like a lot of guys like Eddie,
Eddie will cross his feet over the,
uh,
the face and then hold the leg to keep you from Bob Bucking around.
Ron is like,
go ahead bitch.
Go Buck around cause I'll just roll with you.
I'll just roll with you.
And in the transition I'll fucking grab that thing and make it even tighter.
She's incredible man.
And she saw,
it's ridiculous.
I tweeted for Fox sports one yesterday.
I did a one of those Fox sports,
one shows talking about,
uh,
the UFC and talking about fights and I tweeted something about curling.
That's hilarious.
I couldn't believe it.
People got mad at me.
One of the Olympic curling guys got mad at me and I retweeted his shit.
Oh my God.
That poor pastor got attacked.
I feel bad for him.
I didn't think it was that big of a deal that I call it dumb shit.
I like a lot of dumb shit.
It's nothing wrong with dumb shit.
Why don't you care what I'd like to,
but people were getting so offended.
A woman said,
shame on you.
That's what she said to me.
No,
last week on the podcast,
I thought,
fucking if you need a blow torch to smoke weed,
go fuck you.
See,
I mean you fucking crack,
right?
I want you to understand what marijuana is and you want to show up with a
fucking blow torch to my fucking house,
but a rock and put oil and people keep telling me like,
go,
you got to,
I did it one time.
I'm like,
this ain't for me guys.
I don't see,
it was like freebasing for me.
Yep.
I never understood the drama.
Just give me customer this fucking,
I got to pull it.
I got to put it in a sock and cook it and then you know,
I went to a party one time,
like 25 grams of coke in 1982 I'm not kidding you.
I went and I bought those little vibe when they used to come and bottles already
and I bought the guy out and I fucking went to this house and all I wanted to do
with snoring,
get my dick sucked and this fucking white dude,
you know,
it was like,
oh,
we don't snort cocaine here.
You got to cook it and then put it through a silk sock.
A Silk Kanka shift.
If it's not silk,
it's not going to work and it takes 20 minutes just to do it and then we got to
do it.
Fuck that.
Just give me the code.
It's the same thing with those fucking dabs.
My buddy came over,
he puts a rock on your desk,
then they melted.
Then you've got to take a straw and you cock your ass off.
Said No,
just give me just roll the fuck.
I sat down on the podcast guys.
I got tormented.
Yeah.
People were like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
You know what you're talking about with Deb's.
I'm hearing what I'm saying.
If you need a blow torch to get high,
there's a fucking problem.
I don't give a fuck what it does to you.
You know what?
I smoke a fucking joint and I get stoned to the Goddamn Gill's.
That's all I need.
I'll eat an edible and I get fucked up on those too,
but fucking Babs,
it's really sad too because we had talked about this before,
like the places up north and stuff that they have these dab houses where you
walk in and everyone has a glass pipe.
It's like being in a crack house.
It's the closest thing.
Does the same graph?
Pardon me?
That that kind of stuff has always been like,
well,
you get high or I'm better than you.
Like this is what I'm doing.
Like you're a fucking idiot if you have to go this far to fucking do this shit.
Like if I,
it's like making meth gatoraid even make method of fucking again.
Never make meth out of the gate Gatorade.
I see how they do that shit.
I'm discovery Bro.
They took a Gatorade thing and you put a lighter fluid in there and you put up
fucking cop,
cop a battery in there.
You'll rip it open and you put cold medicine in that motherfucker and who's
shake that mother fuck up for a few minutes.
Put it in a sock and you snort it.
Oh my God,
they could.
They can make meth at the fucking house now.
Who makes met at the fucking house right outside you do it.
Like I could be in here,
put the chemicals together,
go out to,
it's called Shaker or whatever the fuck that shit is.
Shake her up man.
I don't fucking know.
You know that's one of the ways that catch people.
Sometimes it's,
then they start doing meth.
They start keeping it at their house and doing crazy shit.
Like one guy,
I forget the story.
I think,
I believe it was an Esquire,
one of those magazines,
Gq or something like that.
And he was,
uh,
an attorney.
It's somehow or another,
he got hooked up with math,
started doing math and the way they caught him,
he had buckets full of it and his basement just kept it laying around,
like just made it and kept it there.
And we'll just like store and Methodist basement didn't even think there's
anything crazy about storing enough drugs in your fucking house to put you away
for the rest of your life.
And he did hit him.
It was just like,
just had it laying around like wasn't even thinking it was just you're,
you're,
you,
you lose one of the things and when you do the math is that you lose your
ability to see what's and what's not smart.
Like you just,
you lose that with every drug.
It's just not meant.
Don't blame it on meth.
Don't blame.
And I met,
met they,
I don't think we lose it with weed.
No,
but you lose it with the heart.
You get delirious and get your judgment is fucking foil.
That's what drugs do to your judgment is fucking off and you catch yourself
sometimes you're like,
what the fuck did I just do?
Wow.
That's the scary part about sometimes you're like,
what the fuck did I just,
and that's what a lot of people are looking for,
right?
A lot of people are looking for this fucking big burst of,
of escape.
You know,
they're looking for something that just blows the mat or whatever the fuck their
life is because they're looking to just escape.
They don't like life.
They don't like it.
They want you die,
man.
When you get hot and they want to get high to escape,
escape reality,
you know,
man,
we get like your back hurts,
your back hurts,
you hurt your back.
It fucking hurts,
bro.
You got to go to a doc that,
you know the idea.
I did a butterfly sweep.
I left my son with on.
The fucking guy landed on my head.
Oh Gee.
Wow.
My son hurt and swell up.
I think when I needed the drugs,
he was one of my whole body was in pain and it's not pain that you feel.
It's just this pain and it's,
well,
it's also,
you did it for so long when your body became accustomed to using it beginnings.
But in the beginning,
why is the main reason we get down?
Why is the main reason a guy like you and lose you have pain in your life
growing up?
We all do.
What made you different than not doing it?
You know,
when you,
uh,
when you first get involved in that,
your body hurts man.
I kinda,
you know,
when I was 17 I go home at the end of the night when I was in school,
I had to go to school at seven 30.
It's not going high school.
Junior had to go to school and I would come home and sit in the corner in the
dark with headphones on.
What an eight track.
Black Sabbath.
And I just do coke till three in the morning.
Is Christ?
No drinking just to cope.
What possessed you to do that?
Joe wrote,
I don't know.
What's it,
cause that was a junkie.
No,
I was,
you know what?
I was in so much pain.
What's it,
but pain covers this huge thing when you're doing drugs.
Pain could be,
uh,
you know,
fucking confusion.
Pain shows up as confusion.
Confusion shows up as pain is what I'm saying to you.
You confused.
So I was 16.
It could be emotional pain.
It could be as long as she doesn't have to be physical.
Whole body's in pain and you're doing it.
You know,
I talked to the head that I talked to the kid I kidnapped,
you know,
I call them a lot now.
Wow,
I'm guilty.
I'm really fucking guilty of that because I saw something when I get knocked
them that it's not Joe Diaz.
I saw him suffering.
I saw him at one moment on the floor,
handcuffed.
And I would never want that to me.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I always dreaded that happens to a friend of mine for what I did.
And I always felt bad.
I had him call on the podcast and I apologize to them and I always call him up
and I called him the other day and we were talking and they told me,
you know,
every time I talk to him,
he tells me more about his life,
Bro.
You know what happened since I kidnapped them.
I bumped into him in [inaudible] 94.
I kidnapped them and 87,
I bumped into him in [inaudible] 94 and I bought coke from him.
He was all fucked up.
It's at,
uh,
at pro street down in boulder.
And then he never remembered.
I think he blacked out.
That's how bad a shape he was.
And I asked him the last,
not this time,
but at the time before I asked him,
do you remember me buying blow from you?
He goes,
I remember seeing it.
I remember hating you the next day.
I believe I didn't knock you the fuck out because I caught him off guard.
He was at a bar all fucked up.
I'm like,
God saw me some blogs.
Like I look who's here,
the guy who kidnapped me,
the guy who could that me,
but I called him like he kidnapped him in before you apologize for kidnapping
next year later you guys,
Wellman,
I saw him at a bar and Pro Street and you even say,
I'm sorry I kidnapped her.
Not that night.
I just gave him a hug and asked him if he knew where I get some blow and shit.
Not that night he gave me a hug and I always go on the bottom and when I
apologize,
that felt really bad.
And I talked to him,
he and Danny and he started telling me he's 50 he was,
it was mother.
He had a heart attack,
you know,
I could tell when I talked to him and then his pictures on Facebook that he had
a stroke,
you know,
that was off from the blow bro.
Sometimes when he calls me in and I could tell he's drinking,
you know,
and sometimes I feel real guilty that I do this,
but then,
you know,
I'm the type of guy,
I don't play that shit.
You know,
I don't play that shit at all.
He was fucked up when I get in that though,
a couple of weeks before,
you know how we got,
how this whole thing started was because he got a Dui fucked up some cars,
went to bold the hospital on North Hospital,
boulder general.
And while he was in there,
you know,
boulder,
he was hurt.
They left them in a room by himself and he stole a bottle,
liquid coke cans and jumped out the window.
Okay.
And they called them an hour later on the other side of the boat when you steal
a bottle of liquor,
cocaine from the hospital,
you already got pro.
I'm like,
God kidnapping him,
you know,
and we laugh and we giggle.
Meet kidnapping him.
It makes me feel like maybe I contribute to that,
but I didn't.
He had his own doom.
Why didn't I get fucked up?
You know?
I mean,
I got fucked up in different ways.
I paid in different ways because the guilt in me doing that to a man fucking
destroyed me.
You know,
I like to fuck around.
I could do something bad if somebody harms me.
But even with Jujitsu,
I just can't put my forum in some of these face man.
I hate when I have to lay on somebody.
Like I'll check on them and go,
are you okay bro?
You know I love you right now.
Look at me.
No,
I know.
You know it's funny.
So for me,
seeing him in that corner,
I always had that guilt that I tied him up show it's fucking scary when,
well it seems like that was the life you were both living,
you know now that,
yes,
yes.
Apologize.
And you know,
you,
you were on,
you're both on a fucking crazy path.
You know the fucking eighties the eighties that's what it was.
I assist all those movies.
They're writing,
dodged,
all that stuff.
I dodged all that stuff.
Cause the 80s were my period of athletic competition.
It was all hibernation from 81 to 88 all I did was taekwondo.
That's all I did.
February dodged at all.
February,
1919 79 was the day my life went down.
You know why?
Why I got my one,
uh,
I want to form in a karate tournament.
I was a purple belt.
I was in the eighth grade and I lost the fighting.
I got disqualified for kicking above the fucking face.
You were really young.
How old were you?
I was 13 or 14.
It was semi contact and I got out of Goshen route karate and you know,
I liked those guys.
That's why I missed that whole thing because on the weekends we just got a
different fucking tournament's.
You know when you do that and as a kid you just go to different tournament's.
On Saturdays we would all geek out and go to Honda.
You know what a Honda is in New York?
That's a big martial art supplies.
I would geek out nail like I Kabuto Topfers I get the fucking things that you
could punch the Maki Juarez.
I had to fucking the fucking that technique fucking thing.
The juice you put on your palms,
I was the real deal,
you know,
that was watching Chinese connection.
When was the last time you want Chinese guy tonight when everybody goes to
sleep,
put on Bruce Lee's second movie.
Do me that favor goopy that fucking favor and you're going to see what fucking
unreal is.
Poke some Bruce Lee.
You're going to see the last scene of Chinese connection.
The last scene when he goes into the school,
listen to what he says.
Remember Chinese connection is a,
is kind of a rip off of Spaghetti Westerns.
If you watch those three movies Clay's with made in Italy,
there's so far we've gone like you haven't watched them in 20 years watching the
good,
the bad,
and yet what's the tiny paint?
The town red.
I don't remember that.
That was crazy.
That was a great movie.
Great movie.
And back as a ghost story.
He was a ghost story and Chinese connection.
He comes back as a student that they killed his teacher and he Avengers is
teacher and it just the new chuck scene and the Chinese collection when he first
attached to school,
when he goes in and he goes,
I'm allowing you to leave.
Who allows you to leave.
Even in Bronx Tale,
they lock the fucking door and they wouldn't let the bike is.
Leave this right here.
Look at it.
Changed America forever.
This was 1970 look at this guys,
watch this.
I still remember the fucking commercial for this.
The trailer.
Look at how slow and methodical
they're all fucking jacket off.
Look at this man.
Ladies and gentlemen,
look at him
and they all with Steve McQueen had and Steve Mcqueen one when he had you
talking about his forearms,
this guy's clothes or seven times the size of a man and nobody had ever seen
anybody kicking.
Looking at four 1970 nobody ever seen nothing like this.
I remember being in Catholic school at sacred heart school for boys and seeing
this and losing my fucking mind,
but this is nothing.
I'm going to show you the scene with James American forever,
right here.
The double points for both of them right here.
Bam,
right here.
This changed America forever,
Ladies and gentlemen,
that Double Park.
Nobody's ever done that,
right?
Yes.
When they say,
why,
why?
I says,
Joe Rogan,
this is all beauty.
This will never happen again,
but you can see
this was going to America for oh one guy hit him in the back.
This is what America pays forever.
Right here.
Guy fucked up and kicked him in the back room.
That mean it's looking at it.
It was 1970 nobody had ever seen before that nobody
that shit.
How many times do you hit yourself in the back of the head?
Back of my head were bruises.
Fuck.
I've probably have more PTSD from getting hit in the head by my own nunchucks
and never getting punched or kicked.
I would crack myself,
man,
fucking hard.
Those Coco Bolo ones from centrally martial arts supply,
Coco Bolo,
nunchucks they were fucking like a pound each.
They bounce off the back of your head.
I still feel knots in my head.
I still feel knots in bag in my head from where
I was doing it wrong.
You're supposed to go up and catch it behind you,
but I was going this way and catching it like that.
I was kidding.
I didn't know what I was doing.
I was ad libbing,
whacking myself in the back of the head,
just going,
oh fuck.
And then right back to it.
This is just as just as too much.
I remember still going back to school that Monday and kids will lose me.
I still remember the drive in theater.
I strongly set.
We'll put that final fight scene because that's one of the greatest,
he jumps over a table and flying psychics and motherfucker,
no stocks,
no nothing.
He gets the soil,
it takes a guy born.
He fights.
This is the end.
This is the end when they're going to kill him.
Look at Bruce Fleet and he just stands there looking at me.
He fucking just runs out of its before he single handedly
made being Chinese sexy.
Don Don,
Don,
Don.
Ah,
that's the song on,
ah,
this is my life dog.
Midnight,
go fucking midnight.
We'd
just just,
this is just too much.
Yeah.
I don't think anybody
day can realize what an impact that guy had on kids.
I was living in Newark and I was at an apartment building and the superintendent
of the building,
his kid was my age.
I used to go over his house.
That's how I found out about Bruce Lee hit him in his,
he had an older brother and they were really into Bruce Lee and they were a,
you know,
yeah,
like Bruce Lee posters and shit,
and I was like,
Whoa,
what is this Bruce Lee's chef here you guys are into?
And then from there,
I'm pretty sure we went to see a movie together.
I think we went with his dad.
That was the first time I was exposed to it.
I was like maybe five or six and I was like,
oh my God.
He taught this country so many fucking things at the time,
like people would just,
you know,
it made everybody,
but it even strengthened like rebellious.
Like if you watch enter the dragon,
there's a partner that you never caught this appointment to a dragon with.
A guy comes in Bob Wall and he goes,
I know Bob.
I know,
you know.
I didn't know Bob too.
He goes,
you must attend the morning ritual,
one uniform,
which he tells him outside.
He throws the punches and shit and the next day he's dressed in white.
Think about that.
Everybody had a gian.
Bruce Lee refused to wear a fucking gate and he wasn't at his grandfather.
He just refused to wear a fucking g.
That's the kind of mentality you put in these kids.
That's why these kids are getting bits lab.
Do you think of Bruce Lee was around Kolache people be getting bullied.
Nobody got bullied when I was a kid because you watch Bruce Lee,
Bro,
he gave you fucking balls.
Would you please put that last thing you ever got bullied?
What are you talking about?
This still got bullied.
Think have a bullied by people who are trying to find connection at fire.
Fight scene in the end.
Trust me,
it's on the,
I just watched it the other day on Youtube.
I was watching this shit the other day crying.
This is tremendous,
but it's hard to look back when you look back at that and see the kind of impact
that hat at the time.
It's just,
it's hard to wrap your head around it because nobody had ever seen anything like
that before.
There had been no karate movies and all of a sudden,
I mean maybe there was a couple,
but it was nothing like five fingers of death came out.
There was like a two or three then this guy and faded and the beauty of this
was,
and I told us I want to Ari's story tellers that especially for me dog,
you know,
before Bruce Lee,
everybody was walked Chinese people especially walking around,
they were the help pro.
They would have fucking help.
They walked around half retarded.
We came out,
Bruce,
they were ironing shirts and bowing and motherfuckers,
Bruce Lee came out and gave them this inner strength.
But for me,
I wasn't Chinese,
I was Cuban,
I was an immigrant.
I knew what it was to walk around feeling like you were number two.
So for me,
he fucking strengthened my head just watching that shit like that Chinese
motherfucker do.
Dude,
I could do it.
Then my stepfather would come home cause I used to go to karate and my
stepfather go,
what'd you learn today?
And I teach them and he'd go,
don't work on me.
And I go,
what the fuck?
You know what I'm saying?
It just worked at the karate school and don't work here.
And he would tell him,
you know I don't work cause I smacked the shit out of Bruce Lee and Cuba one
time and I believe him.
He would tell him that,
fuck Bruce Lee at one time on the corner and Cube I bit slap met that Chinese.
He was bullshitting me.
The man,
my mother would tell me Batman was a Faggot,
you know shit like that.
There's this scene that's it.
You got to speed it up a little bit more but what?
Fuck it,
we'll take that too.
What's this one?
He was also the first guy that was like really shredded like that in movies
where it taking place.
There's when he fights,
misses a Zukie.
This is what the sword,
look at this guys,
this is just tremendous.
Was there ever a guy that was like shirtless and movies?
It was flexing beforehand.
Was that a thing?
Because the guy was ripped Hercules.
Yeah,
but not like a fighter guy.
Right.
Tarzan.
Because everything else was after like a hard times Bronson.
That was much later.
Right?
Oh,
look at this fight.
Look at his fight here.
Pharaoh,
Pharaoh.
But no,
just play this fight off the Joe.
There's one scene in here where you look at him and you go,
well,
you know why he couldn't be fake,
but look at his hand speed.
There wasn't no speedups and filming this.
There wasn't nothing.
This fight with this guy I think was a Russian that was coming to visit him,
but this is just tremendous hole from the fucking time he walks in.
It's a 20 minute fight.
The first movie does is a spinning elbow front.
Kate,
who does that?
So he walked,
he walked in.
There was two.
Jack is this right here?
We get to see it right here before that.
He goes like this.
He walks out.
You got,
you got to get to the microphone.
Man Kicks Him.
They don't do that shit no more.
They don't do that shit.
Put that.
I didn't even hear what you said.
He's playing the sound and you're talking shit.
Okay.
Oh my God.
That guy.
The white belt.
What's his,
what's his handling?
Watch his feet.
Watch his fucking speed dog.
This is 1970 there was no speed up films.
It's also the sounds that he made but crazy.
Don't play that music friend.
What's your spinning?
What's this?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Pressing questions.
Bam.
This motherfucker stand now.
This fight scene by [inaudible] that the movie theaters at my boys and we
watched it and then we go next door to mark was dishonest.
Glutamine.
Knock all the fucking food plots.
Oh look,
I got him in the arm up bro.
This is real.
This is 20th Oh my God.
Bruce Lee.
He fucked up.
I think I had any technique.
What do you really fight him?
He let go because of a bite.
He bit him in the fucking ankle real fucking hard.
That was good arm bar technique for 1970 or whatever it was.
What year was this?
Just came out?
This was the original heroin movie.
Just came out like a 70 look at him.
Go
transcend this motherfucker with his hands.
If you haven't watched the challenge connection,
you'll fuck it up.
And he's like,
Steve Mcqueen every 10 minutes because he's really angry in this movie because
they killed his teacher.
He's fucking them up.
Baula hate in this fucking movie.
Who's on the phone with Steve Mcqueen who were sleep?
You mean talking to them?
Telling them what do I do?
Maxim the fuck up.
But watch this.
This is a Steve McQueen's in the movie.
Is that what you're saying?
Boom.
Bow is buses.
Joe Rogan.
Watch this.
Oh,
come on now.
That guy just ate a wheel kick.
This is unrealistic.
It's sat quick.
But if guy,
when you get wheel kicking their face,
dude,
this is awesome though.
This is tremendous.
You saw this still good.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
This fucking seat.
This is just too much.
You know?
Look,
his technique is really fucking good.
It's really good to this day.
I mean,
it's hard to see someone do martial arts from back then and compare it to what
you see today.
But Bruce Lee compares.
It's really good kicking technique,
man.
Like his side.
Kick it straight.
He's not kicking.
His hip comes up,
it goes straight.
That's where it gets good.
Fuck this mother.
Fuck up right now for Joe Rogan.
Suzuki.
Why is this Joe Rogan watch this?
Watch this dog.
Old School.
Fuck the
fuck God.
He makes it crazy.
Scream when he karate fucking,
he goes out.
Zukie
he fucks up Suzuki.
Then he goes back to his school and they tell him,
you know,
you gotta go do some time and he fucking grabs the guy and he goes,
listen,
don't touch my school.
I'll fuck you up.
Then he walks outside.
He agreed to do time.
This is the beauty about Bruce Lee.
He's agreed to do the time.
He walks out and he opens a door on there.
All that is,
shoot him.
That's the scene you see.
He could have turned around and away.
That motherfucker looked at them,
yelled and ran out until the audience and it ends with him doing the fly psychic
and you hear the bullets going off and you're just ready to go.
Kill somebody at that point.
[inaudible]
I'm fucking somebody up to that.
And that's how he left you off.
That was it.
And then return of the dragon came out with Chuck Norris and that was kind of
Ah,
people bad time.
He,
no,
he didn't die yet.
Enter the dragon came out July of 73 and he was dead.
Maybe a week later.
He died a week after that until the dragon came out.
He died July something [inaudible] 73 so I was 10 let me tell you something.
When he died,
you have no idea what this country was like because there was no internet.
You had to find out by going to Chinatown.
That was the proof.
You got to go to Chinatown and buy the magazines and they showed you the black
and white pictures of him carrying him and his wake,
Kareem Abdul Jabbar and James Cobra.
And it wasn't,
there was no newspaper.
Nobody cared about some Chinese guy that was,
we didn't find that to a month after he died that they sent us a letter by the
fucking it up
bottle with a note.
You know what's really fascinating about him,
man,
he made his movies and all of his like scenes with these wild kicks and jumping
fighting techniques,
but in real life when he practiced martial arts for fighting for,
he never did any of that stuff.
He concentrated on like low kicks and punches and boxing techniques mixed with
wrestling techniques,
but he just knew that it would be spectacular looking spectacular.
Yeah,
it was guy was 30 years ahead of his time guy he really wanted,
he'd get to society what he did to the film industry.
What he did,
he brought something that was just brilliant
and then you watch anther drag them and they just cashed them up.
They just so listen,
you come back with us and then the Chinese people got mad and that was heroin
money.
They made those movies for $10 in Thailand or would have fucked him.
So he had some sort of crazy,
there's some crazy conspiracy theory about his death that it was absolutely
Chinese mob that killed him because he owed money and so money,
he just took money out of their pocket.
When he left,
he went out with a born abroad.
You think that's what happened?
Did they kill him?
What happened really would make them barrels and money.
How much money do you think the Chinese connection cost to shoot?
What they think they paid those Thailand people?
Well,
it's kind of crazy when you find out that his son died as well and died because
there was a bullet in a gun was supposed to be a blank gun or it had a piece in
it or something like that.
There's something in it will never fuck.
But if you were thinking like that,
some really crazy,
really rich Chinese gangster guy won his son dead as well.
Some real old school Kangaskhan type shit.
Kill the man and then,
and then put a hit on his son and that,
that's how it went down.
I mean,
I don't know what happened to him.
I don't know.
But that's always been the conspiracy theory.
It's people,
you know,
people love those kinds of crazy stories.
They love the crank.
Crazy story of,
uh,
you know,
a curse on him or I never thought about Milk Kirsch or the Samurai touched his
back like any shit,
Sam.
I trust him with the murder of touch,
but it is crazy.
When we got a blood clot,
Brandon me was killed.
This was my philosophy.
The Dea never talks about heroin coming from Chinese.
Chinese been bringing heroin into this country since Jesus loves Chicago,
but they're that smart.
Yeah,
that's
smart.
They don't flaunt it.
When you see a Chinese restaurant,
what do you see?
You see 50 people.
When you see white people in their server and not the whole family's in there.
When you to a good Chinese restaurant,
what do you see?
You see the kid and the two kids doing homework at the table.
The whole family runs it.
They all move in together.
They all do all that shifts so they know they're not Puerto Ricans broke and not
fucking Italians that buy a Lincoln continental,
look at me.
They can keep it low that they never could get busted.
They have such a great system.
The triads,
those Chinese gangsters.
Remember that the mafia concept is not Italian.
It's Chinese.
It's Chai fucking knees.
So Spaghetti,
well I don't know about snow.
That oodles noodles came from China.
They brought her to Italy.
The Italians came over to China,
found noodles,
brought it back to Italy and said,
oh we made me and balmy mix.
We got feathers.
I'm trying to power.
So I think that they made all this money in China,
wherever they made these movies.
Cause after that the producers of him or run one shore and Raymond Chow,
Raymond chapter,
briefly die.
Rehmann shop became a break partner Warner brothers.
In fact,
he produced a bunch of a Charles Bronson movies.
Wow.
Do you understand me?
So there was a lot of Kinky shit going on and then 30 years later they killed
his son.
If you watch godfather two what does he do?
He kills the fucking son's.
He lets veto live.
Vito goes back to the United States,
gets powered cars back,
bye bye.
And turn the machine on Tuesday.
They're not going to stick.
Those are good for you out of your or salmon flights,
bro.
He knows.
Go to a doctor,
a salmon.
I did a little bear fart.
It's terrible arts.
A bear forest in your face and you don't have to turn it.
I'm really just sit down.
That's the core with some emphasis protein in that motherfucker.
Oh,
Joey Diaz,
so a where can people check you out?
Where he got a date's coming up this week.
I'm in love.
It's your love it.
That late night,
10 o'clock show just to get warmed up and d still running that place.
You had these back over there.
I'm doing Valentine's 10:00 AM Saturday 10 o'clock then I'm in Black Boston.
Then I'm in fucking stress factory with Vinny.
Vinny,
Vinny.
Don't know where he's getting his hands in the hall.
My gangster buddies are coming up everywhere.
Kids are having seen bro again.
They call me again.
We want to fucking table.
Oh one a table and we ain't paying.
I said,
that's fine.
You said they're not paying.
These motherfuckers are grabbed me by the throat.
I'm just fucking around.
These guys are crazy.
Yeah,
but I'm going to have a good time.
Not Everything's going great.
I'm still doing the podcast.
The podcast is still phenomenal.
I released to see the on New Year's Eve.
It's still up there,
you know,
so I want to thank everybody for giving death squad old love in the world,
man.
So,
uh,
that's the Jon Lovitz this weekend.
And then where after that I'm in Laugh Boston,
February 26.
I'm a New Jersey.
March 6th.
I'm in fucking Chicago.
March 13th.
And it is,
um,
what's your website?
Uh,
Joey Diaz doesn't that Joey has done all the tour dates.
Stay there.
Boom.
Ladies and gentlemen,
as for me,
I got a Dallas,
Texas,
Verizon on March 14th
with a Duncan Trussell and Ari Shaffir and then,
uh,
Miami on April 3rd and then Orlando with you on April 18th.
And then Baltimore again with Joey Diaz on,
uh,
April 25th.
Go to Joe rogan.net.
Check out the tour dates.
Brian,
when you got coming up,
you said you had a new date.
Uh,
yeah,
I have a January 28 through March 1st La Jolla comedy store.
Uh,
and then April 18th,
the Portland,
Oregon,
April 19th,
Seattle in April 20th,
Vancouver.
And where they find that.
Jess,
squad.
Dot.
TV.
Boom.
Ladies and gentlemen,
thanks to this new co sponsor,
nature's Barkbox,
tremendous naturebox for a delicious snacks,
delicious snacks that are actually good for you.
Powerful nature box.
Let me pull up their little thing.
Um,
thanks.
Also to,
who else did I Tang,
Tang Tang,
a rogan.tang.com.
Go there.
Save yourself $25 off of any of their new phones.
Ah,
thanks.
Also to audible.com.
Go to audible.com forward slash Joe and get a free audio book and 33 days of
audible service.
Um,
go to naturebox.com/rogan that's naturebox.com/rogan and a save some money.
What are they going to give you?
If they got a 50,
50% off by going to naturebox.com/rogan and try your first order,
try your first order of a delicious healthy snacks sent right to your door.
Um,
and these things are,
what they're doing is giving you healthy choices.
So instead of going to a vending machine and getting some shit that's going to
be bad for you,
you're getting zero trans fats,
zero high fructose corn Syrup and nothing artificial nature box ships for free.
So that's naturebox.com/rogan alright,
fucks.
Uh,
we love the shit out of you and we'll see you Monday.
Stay black.
Yes.
Okay.